e
chair recognizes the member from Auburn
represent of Osborne who moves at the
house of Jour from the session of May
9th 2024 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppos n
the eyes have it the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a Prayer by
house chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart
pastor of St Paul's United Methodist
Manchester good morning
God good morning New Hampshire house of
rep
Representatives good morning Mr
prayer oh god of us all we give our
thanks to you for this great state of
New
Hampshire we give you thanks for the
seeds of Hope planted for our state and
our
country when we as a nation walk in your
way grant us Grace
to continue in your
will when we as your children fall
short we ask you to correct us and
forgive
us as we draw near to Memorial
Day May we pause for a moment to
remember those who have served
you our
guide us oh God as we the New Hampshire
House of
Representatives begin our work
today guide us to make the best
decisions
possible our decisions may affect those
constituents we
represent through the legislation we
work on
today may they be Seeds of Hope for for
a brighter future for us
all oh god of love again I ask that you
bless each member and leader of this New
Hampshire House of
Representatives grant them your peace
and Grace as they navigate through the
business of this day give each member
and leader a a portion of your wisdom as
they execute the business set before
them this day to the best of their
abilities
oh god of us all as we plant the seeds
for the great state of New Hampshire
today we ask if you would water and
fertilize those seeds
planted in so doing it will bring glory
and praise to your holy name for you are
the alpha and the Omega in our lives it
is in our love for you oh God we pray
amen
chair recognizes a member from
Manchester sen Brian Cole who would send
Pledge of
Allegiance Al to the FL flag of the
United States of America the for it
stands one nation God indivisible withy
all the chair now recognizes Ella Smith
a senior at John Stark Regional High
[Music]
anthem by the dawn's
early
light what so
proudly we
held at the
Twilight last GLE in who BR stripes and
bright
stars through the
pess
fight or the ramp parts we
watch were so
gallantly
streaming and The
Rock red
glare the boms bursting
in
air gave proof through the
night that our flag was still
there oh say does that star
spangled
away or the
free and the
home of the bread
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for Le
of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives bone buo HR Lloyd and
O'Brien the day important business
Representatives Belcher mccon Maria
these Le of option shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the
house house will attend the introduction
of guests Mr Speaker please welcome
Lucas trong student at Lincoln Woodstock
[Applause]
Mr Speaker please welcome Laura louder
Smith Larry and Laura Smith mother uncle
and Aunt of the singer guests of
Representative Cole Lori Kristen Jeremy
and Christopher Shepard guests of
Representative Lon Jacob garide guest of
Representative elberger Roman skull
guest of Representative NAB Mark fiser
guest of Representative priest Karen
Bernett Curry guest of Representative
buroughs Elena Colby guest of
Representative Brennan John Hall son of
representative Hall Ellen rockmore Jean
Brown Kimberly Frost and Nancy CER and
fourth grade students from Crossroads
Academy guests of Representatives hacken
Phillips Jim Murphy and Mirad they are
with us in the gallery today Welcome to
the New Hampshire
[Applause]
[Music]
house the house will attend to a
communication
Mr
Speaker in a communication dated May
15th Mr Speaker I have relocated my
family to wear New Hampshire and as of
today I will no longer reside in my
district I therefore must resign my
position as state representative of the
Hillsboro 39th District effective upon
receipt of this letter of course I would
like to thank the voters of Manchester
Awards 68 and9 and formerly the voters
of Lichfield for entrusting me to fight
for them in conquer while I will miss
the Queen City my wife and I which wish
to raise our son Maverick in a more
rural environment which M Manchester
cannot understandably provide I fully
believe that Manchester's brightest days
are ahead of it thank you for entrusting
me with two chairmanships this term I
would like to say to my colleagues on
Election law that despite our
acrimonious final meeting we did manage
to accomplish a lot and a committee
known for its partisanship was usually
and thankfully congenial this is largely
due to the good faith effort of
Representative Lane who is a calming
force on the committee I believe we made
significant progress on a addressing the
child care crisis facing our state and I
would like to thank representative
walner for being a partner in finding
solutions to ease the burden on New
Hampshire's Working Families finally I
would like to thank my wife Sammy for
being an amazing mother wife and
business partner being 34 years old and
still working means she has picked up my
slack when I am in conquered and I will
be forever grateful to her I wish you
and the rest of the Committees uh the
members well and go give the Senate hell
in Committee of conference best
Rasberry resignation accepted the house
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on executive departments and
administration Senate Bill 485 removed
by Representatives Spain Hull nder rort
Moffett Tom Manion kushman mcarter Wei
and Jonathan Smith from the Committee on
Public Works and highways Senate Bill
543 removed by Representatives Vose nter
PL Carol Brown Doug Thomas OS Bor
ples are there any other bills be
removed sen Bosman moves at the consent
calendar with the relevant amendments as
printed in the today's house record be
adopted are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have consent calendar is
adopted for what reason is a member rise
uh Mr Speaker I move to special order
Senate Bill 411 to the first order of
business
to right
now chair recognize you to speak to your
motion oh sorry um thank you Mr Speaker
I move that we special order Senate Bill
411 um to be the current
business sorry recog you to speak oh to
speak to the bill sorry thank you Mr
Speaker um Senate Bill 411 would allow
for a committee to look at the mental
health services because frankly right
now we have too many people slipping
through the cracks I have constituents
who are the people that you would expect
that could navigate this the mother is
Works in this space the mother
understands social work because she is a
social worker her son needed help and he
didn't get the help that he needed for
far too long I ask that you approve this
bill so that we can have a study
committee and that so that we can invite
Mrs uh invite my constituent to bring
her knowledge as both a professional and
a mother in order to share this and help
us find these cracks that our our youth
are falling through in the mental health
system so I ask for your support on this
very important Bill thank
you the motion before us is special
order Senate Bill 411 are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
majority of the committee on Health and
Human Services elderly Affairs to which
was referred Senate Bill 411 FN and act
establishing a committee to study
emergency Mental Health Services for
person 21 years of age and younger in
New Hampshire considered the same report
the same with the recommendation the
bill ought to pass sen ver Lon for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee have
been consider the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate of yri P off
for the minority of the committee chair
Leon thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
members for the house of um special
ordering this I have my constituents
here in the balcony and I hope that uh
you will vote Yes on this bill so that
we can make sure that nobody falls
through these cracks anymore thank
you the motion before us is the majority
committee report of a to pass and Senate
Bill 411 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes haven't in the committee
adopted the house will now attend to the
Affairs for what reason does a member
rise uh I would request a special
order uh a member of the Commerce
Committee would very much like to
participate in this debate and her
husband is being sworn in to the bar
association this morning so we are asked
that uh we would move this to the first
thing after
lunch okay the motion is to special
order Senate Bill
558 to this first bill after
lunch are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I a you guys have
it and Senate Bill 558 is special
ordered
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
referred Senate Bill 418 FN
an act relative to refusal of consent to
testing to determine alcohol
concentration penalties for aggravated
driving while intoxicated considered the
same report the same with a
recommendation the bill ought to pass
representative Dennis Manion for the
committee minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate sen of laurine seig for the
minority of the committee the chair
seake thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning I am here to speak in opposition
to the ought to pass motion for Senate
Bill 418
FN Mr Speaker do I believe people should
operate a vehicle while under the
influence of any substance absolutely
not but I do believe that people have
the right of due process and they should
understand and the consequence of their
actions the current penalty for um for a
First Defense refusal to comply with a
chemical test request for impaired
driving is a six-month administrative
license suspension this bill would
double the length of suspension from six
months to a full year the department of
safety complaints New Hampshire's
current refusal rate of 70% nearly
double the national average would be
substantially reduced because of the new
higher refusal penalty which would be
set to one year it would be greater than
and the penalty for complying in testing
which remains at 180 days dos also
believes the increased penalty for
refusing the test would dispel the
perception that refusing testing is the
smarter way to go because the suspension
for impaired driving for a firsttime
offense after testing positive would
remain at 6 months during the hearing we
heard that many drivers including
commercial drivers who depend on their
vehicles to earn a living wrongly assume
they can refuse to take the test with no
consequences doubling the penalty to a
year would have an adverse impact on
many people in New Hampshire a first
offender who has a license taken away
for a year has tremendous collateral
damage when it comes to employment
housing and getting groceries especially
in rural part of the state where there's
no public
transportation now Mr Speaker we also
heard testimony the current paperwork
given to people to show the consequences
of refusal is confusing at best we heard
in debate that 16-year-olds when 16year
we heard in debate that when
16-year-olds get their licenses they
sign a contract with implied consent
that they will always agree to a
breathalizer test even though they
cannot drink for five more years legally
and if your teens are anything like mine
remembering something specific for five
years or more is not exactly realistic
I've been asking them to put the milk
back in the fridge since they were five
and I'm still
waiting we've also heard that the way
people will learn about these increased
suspensions will be through an
advertising campaign
and a better designed
form however would it not make more
sense to redesign the form
now and provide public service
announcements on current law to see what
difference that can make in people's
behaviors surely our goal is better
compliance with the law and better
compliance with people choosing never to
drive while under the influence of any
substance
ever um given the level of
misunderstanding regarding the
consequence of refusal that came out at
the public hearing and the lack of
emphasis on communicating this over the
years it raises the possibility and
probability there may be more of a
Communications or perception problem
than a penalty problem truly Mr Speaker
this bill is anti-liberty and one that
will penalize most those with the fewest
assets as one defense attorney told me
those who will benefit most from this
change in law will be the defense
attorneys who will get a huge surge in
clients this bill will not change change
Behavior it will just create more
billing opportunities for those
lawyers finally Mr Speaker I urge the
body to vote no on OTP so another motion
can be made and encourage the interested
parties to modify the current forms to
increase Clarity and use their intended
funds for advertising on ensuring people
understand the current penalties for
refusal as well as for reminding people
that it is never under any circumstances
okay to drive under the influence and Mr
please chair recognize your
Manion thank you Mr Speaker I don't have
a speech prepared for this but I've been
a larm force for 30 years and we are at
the bottom of the list for states in the
country that have uh such low penalties
for refusing to take a blood or breast
test
uh this is going to increase it from 6
months to a year um it's going to
incentivize more people to take the test
uh and that's going to make our road
safer so as far as the it being a
comprehension or a reading issue uh as
opposed to uh people not taking it
because they don't understand the
bill the these forms are read verbatim
they have to be read verbatim to the
people uh that are under arrest so they
understand the form fully each line is
read word for word the instructions on
the back are given to the people about
how long they're going to lose their
license if they uh refuse on a first
offense um raising it from 6 months to a
year is not a big ass it's going to put
us in line with the rest of the country
uh too many people are dying on the
roads uh we need to make people uh more
incent incentivized to take these tests
a lot of times the administrative
license suspension is pled out if
someone has a plea on a DUI anyways so
it may be a moot point at the end of the
day but
um raising it from six months to a year
it's it's it's time we uh we do that I I
encourage you to press the green button
on this not to pass motion thank you
does the member yield the
questions does the member yield the
questions member
yields thank you Mr speaker thank you
representative for for taking my
question forgive my ignorance but do you
know what the maximum loss of license
penalty is for a first offense DWI in
New Hampshire currently
if you're
convicted so if you're convicted for DUI
it's um could be up to two years but
it's
a uh six month loss I believe or N9
month loss and it can have reduced so if
you take the idcmp program which is an
alcohol program in a timely manner you
could have it reduced down to uh I think
it's 90 days for a first offense penalty
for license loss court ordered what
we're talking about here is
Administrative so this is an addition to
it it but it's a potential two years
potential twoe thank you does the member
yield to further questions no I don't
member does not
yield rent of Granger has requested a
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is aut to pass on
Senate Bill 418 before we get to the
roll
call we have a long day ahead of
us the noise in this chamber on the
first bill is too
loud the longer we take to allow members
to speak the longer we're going to be
here
tonight and so I'm making a honest
request to all of
you when you hear that there is a
division or a roll call move as quickly
possible to your seat and if you need to
have a conversation please take it out
into the anti room so we can move as
fastly as we can dur for the course of
this day it's going to be a long
day now the motion before us is ought to
pass in Senate Bill 418 this is a roll
call vote chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that our current six-month
license suspension for refusing to
comply with a chemical test is already
in line with similar penalties in other
states and if I know that doubling the
length of suspension to a full year for
a first offense would impose tremendous
collapse feral damage on first offenders
who depend on their vehicles to earn a
living in a state where many people live
in rural areas with no access to public
transportation and if I also know that
our state's implied consent law is
widely misunderstood and makes it just
as likely that New Hampshire's chemical
test refusal problem is more a
communication problem than a penalty
problem then would I press the red
button so another motion can be made
thank you Che recognized representative
Roy for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
New Hampshire is the second of all
states and refusals and if I know it's
no secret we basically learn in high
school don't take the
test and if I further know that if no
one takes the
test our death rate is going to continue
to go up because no one's going to get
convicted especially now with multiple
substance use would I then press thep
green button and make it the incentive
to take the test so that we can get
people help and save lives thank you
motion before us a majority committee
report of Auto passing sen B 4018 this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if your
oppos press the red button voting
[Music]
all members present had opportunity to
vote 101 voting a 253 voting a the
motion
fails representative celic moves
itl are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I
oppos
n the guys have it and the minority
committee on education to which was
referred Senate Bill 340 act relative to
communication between parents and school
districts regarding special education
consider the same report the same with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass sen of Glenn cordelli for the
committee bills on second reading open
to further Amendment representative lad
offers floor Amendment
1995 and the chair recognizes represent
of
Myer thank you Mr Speaker I rise today
to oppose the adoption of amendment
995h to SP
340 special education services to
students families and school districts
is a complicated and a vital program to
provide the necessary support for stud
students with special learning
needs the development of an appropriate
individual education plan or IEP for a
student's Educational Services is
fundamental to the educational success
of a
student having the appropriate
information for the IEP is key in the
development between the parent and
school districts
Representatives careful consideration to
the necessary services for the IEP is is
important for it will be adjusted as the
student progresses through their
educational
experience earlier this month the house
education committee held a briefing with
the legislative budget assistant office
the LBA on the first performance audit
of the special education dispute
resolution process program of the
Department of
Education the audit focused on the
access of parents to special Education
Services the audit was most critical of
the
mismanagement of this service to parents
the department has yet to respond to the
and address the delinquencies noted in
the audit further the LBA has a pending
audit on the total special education
department performance that final report
and its recommendations is outstanding
and will be reported in the forthcoming
months I cite these two audits to note
that there is an outstanding concern
about the management and the operation
of the special education department that
needs to be transparent and identify
needed management
adjustments amendment
9995 is
premature to the to the complete of
these audits of the LBA a once the
audits have been completed then the
needed completed assessment of
addressing the necessary Management
Services can take place it is not
prudent to peac meal or Tinker with
portions of the needed
changes last week the house education
committee met and considered a similar
non- gerine amendment to
340 advocates for the special education
service Services were there in force to
oppose this 11th Hour attempt to modify
current parental access and consent to
special education
services although the amendment 995
eliminates a significant section of the
original non- gerain Amendment it does
not reflect the need to wait and address
the totality of the LBA recommendations
once the final findings are issued
colleagues I hope you would join me in
recognizing the need to wait and address
the full measure of the needed changes
to the administration of the special
education services out of the Department
of Education please vote no on the
amendment 995 thank you very much Mr
dry thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues in March the legislative
budget assistant released a performance
audit specifically on the subject of
special education dispute resolution
processes this amendment is a response
to that audit and will put into statute
the recommendations from the audit
here's what the amendment
does the amendment gives us information
parents have a right to uh object or
reject uh an IEP agreement in total or
in part but we don't know why many of
these are doing this and we don't know
how many of them are doing this and we
don't know if those children are getting
the special ed services that they need
this was mentioned multiple times in the
audit the amendment requires the
department to track the number and
category of those refusals and also to
track the resolutions and the time
needed to resolve those
refusals the amendment also gives us
gives the ad advocate for special
education access to
information it's necessary for her to
fulfill her duties currently in law the
amendment requires the Department of
Education and The Advocate to sign a
memorandum of agreement for this access
in addition The Advocate will be
required to get parental permission for
Access that's required by state or
federal law these are safeguards
currently we're asking the special
education Advocate to do a job and not
giving her the tools to do the job
finally the amendment will give the
state consistency local school districts
can establish their own methods for
solving resolving disputes but those
vary from District to district and they
don't necessarily have to report their
information this in Amendment will
require
local districts to submit their plans to
the department and annually submit
information on local dispute topics and
resolutions these requirements provide
immediate benefits to The Advocate to
resolving IEP disputes and to improving
the dispute resolution process and most
importantly it's a step forward in
helping parents and children with
disabilities please support this
vote this will be a division vote
members take your
seats will a member yield to questions I
will
yield thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question
with another special ed audit due out
next year should we wait and address
time thank you for your question
representative just two months ago the
LBA office released a 112 page complete
audit with a 20page addendum
specifically addressing dispute
resolution if we wait for another audit
what's going to change if we don't act
on this now we'll just be kicking the
can down the road and moving at the
speed of government is not exactly a
compliment we have a chance to make an
this does the member yield to further
yield does your Amendment just Tinker
with portions of special ed changes as
side thank you for the question and
again I'm just going to repeat that this
was specifically uh
addressing uh pieces of the audit and
addressing problems that are in the
audit and it's specifically with dispute
resolution if we want to tackle dispute
resolution this is the time to do it
this is the way to do it it won't get
lost in the shuffle of a total total
audit it was done specifically for a
reason this uh amendment is here to
specifically the motion the motion
before us is aut to pass in Senate Bill
340 this is a division vote members take
re
all right the motion before it's a to
pass on Senate Bill 340 this is floor
Amendment
1995 this is on the amendment that we're
voting chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker if I know the
committee heard hours of testimony from
special education parents teachers and
advocates in opposition to sections that
are in this non-gain amendment and if I
know that state Auditors have cited the
Department's mishandling of special
education complaints and that the state
is now conducting a comprehensive audit
of special education services and if I
the department can approve their own
management practices without this
amendment then would I press the red
button to defeat the amendment and put
the burden on the Department of
Education to get the job done right
thank you chair recognize representative
lad for parliamentary
inquiry good morning Mr Speaker if I
know this amendment was heard in the
education committee and based upon
public testimony the fifth section in
which the vast maor majority of the
public objected to has been deleted from
this amendment if I further know this
amendment has been developed in
cooperation with and assistance from the
director of special education at doe and
legal support representing the
Department of Education and the office
of the advocate for special
education and lastly and perhaps most
important if I know this amendment
includes needed immed immediate
legislative changes as recommended by
the March 2024 LBA performance audit
report that will benefit participants
protect
confidentiality of student IEP records
and improve dispute resolution processes
would I then press the green button
thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass on floor Amendment 1995
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you press the red button
represent all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 184 voting A7 77 voting a four
amendment is adopted the motion before
amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
clarify and I guess from this point on
if I know it's going to be a close vote
and nobody yells for a division and I am
just going to call it on my own so we
don't have to go through a Voice vote
vote all right this is a clarification
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button this is ought to
pass as amended on Senate Bill 340
[Music]
repr have all members present had an
opportunity to vote also attend to state
of the
vote 186 voting a 176 voting aay
for what reason house will be in order
for what reason does a member
rise I'm would like to make a motion
State your motion a motion to table he
hasn't even read it yet I haven't even
committee on Election law to which was
referred CAC R22 relating to the New
Hampshire presidential primary providing
that New Hampshire presidential primary
shall be first presidential primary of
the presidential election cycle
presentive Steven Smith moves are to
pass now
representative thank you Mr speaker now
I'd like to make a motion to table cacr
22 it is a appropriate motion so the
motion before us
yeah may I speak to M it's not debatable
okay okay
would I would like to do a pi you would
back representative Lane has moved to
table cacr
22 this is going to be a division
vote members make sure you take your
request for roll call has been made is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
the motion before us is the table cacr
22 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Lane for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that we tabled an identical Bill almost
a year ago to this day on a motion made
by the then chair of the election law
committee then would I vote green to
table this bill once again thank
you chair recognizes Representative
Steven Smith for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
there's some stuff that needs to be said
and I am interested in hearing the very
short concise debate before we let such
an important question for the voters
pass away would I press the red
button the motion before us is the table
CAC R22 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
representative
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 175 voting aay 187 voting nay the
motion to table fails we're back to
autop pass on cacr 22 chair recognizes
thank you Mr
Speaker the election law
committee discussed the possibility of a
constitutional
amendment entrenching first in the
nation primary New Hampshire in great
detail everyone on the committee every
person on the committee passionately
supports New Hampshire's first and the
nation
primary much of our discussion however
focused
on the possibility that without a
well-organized
well
funded publicity campaign a
constitutional referendum might actually
fail to secure the very high threshold
that referenda have to get in order to
pass when they go to the people to pass
this we need a univocal bipartisan
message to the citizens of New Hampshire
it's not easy in today's politics to get
a
65% vote for anything I have a very very
divided poy and this fall in the
presidential election I anticipate an
evenly split electorate to have a
referenda on that on that ballot that
asks everybody to come together is going
to be a heavy heavy lift and for that
reason on the election law committee
many people who passionately support the
first in the nation primary thought it
would would be imprudent to try to put
this in the Constitution at this moment
consideration was whether
our
venerable New Hampshire Constitution is
location for a law about partisan
primaries
the New Hampshire
Constitution is among the very oldest
Democratic constitutions in the
world it's older obviously than the
United States Constitution we have a
responsibility to respect our
constitution by only amending it when
absolutely
necessary whether this amendment is
necessary remains an open question it's
something that deserves more
consideration more reflection and
deserves the kind of deliberation that
can produce real bipartisan consensus
and so for that reason I'm hopeful that
you'll vote against this ought to pass
motion so that we could make a different
motion sure recogniz Representative
thank you Mr Speaker so we've had a law
that says we go first for a long time
and until recently it has served well
but you know what people aren't taking
it seriously anymore as evidenced by the
fact that in this most recent one we
received a sternly worded letter
ordering us to change our laws change
our date to facilitate the desires of a
political party I would like to remind
them first of all we put it on we pay
for it we set the rules that's just how
it is they should respect that because
when candidates come here they are
coming here to earn the respect and
Trust of Voters lousy way to start and
both parties have done it before you
think I'm throwing partisan attacks out
here so that sternly worded letter what
I'm going to ask you to do today is see
that sternly worded letter and raise on
the voice of the people I'm not afraid
of the answer if we put this on the
ballot the people of New Hampshire have
earned this right for decades there was
a pie of place in Manchester that had a
picture of George W bush serving french
fries that isn't folksy it's not quaint
it's not cute when the candidates come
here and serve our coffee and cook our
eggs it is a reminder to powerful people
who want to be the leader of the Free
World that their first job their only
job is to be a public servant nobody
reminds them of that better than the
people in a Hampshire and I think that
they deserve to have this right that's
already earned
written down in the Constitution or at
the very least I want to hear what they
think don't you I trust the people in
the Hampshire to answer this question
and I want to ask it so I'm asking you
cacr house will be in
order the motion before us is autop pass
on cacr 22 so going to be a division
represent Amon is requested a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
the motion before us is ought to pass in
CAC R22 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Lane for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the first vote on this bill in our
committee was 20 to zero to
itl if I know that when the political
parties hold their primaries does not
belong in our
Constitution and if I know that this
Constitutional Amendment does not bind
either party or any party or any other
state and if I know that we passed a
resolution supporting the first in the
nation Primary in this house earlier
this year on a roll call vote then would
I press the red button so a more
appropriate motion can be made thank you
chair recognize Representative Steven
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I and my 14 years here have
heard many debates about this topic from
us but I want to know what the people
think
and Mr Speaker if I think they deserve
to answer this question and I am not
afraid of their answer whatever it was
and I trust the people that I work for
would I demonstrate that trust Now by
pressing the green
button motion before us is aut to pass
on cacr 22 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote having failed to attain three
fails for what reason does a member rise
i' like to make a motion please State
the motion before us is reconsideration
340 are you ready for the question
division has been requested members take
your seats this will be a division vote
here
motion before us is reconsideration on
Senate Bill 340 if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you press the red button voting
[Music]
represent
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 176 voting a 188 voting a the
committee on executive departments and
administration to which is referred
Senate Bill
373 act relative to the State Building
Code having considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment a
recommendation to Bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen of Sher ghoul for the
committee the amendment is 1855 H
printed in house record 20 Pages 53
through
54 the debate is on the amendment chair
sidtis good morning today I Rise is in
opposition of um non- gerine Amendment
1252 it is um a place where the state
level government does not belong it's a
it's a um communication problem between
two tribes and the tribes
are um under the Bureau of Indian
Affairs and the department of the
interior and so I would ask that you um
defeat this amendment so that um the
bill can come through cleaner thank
gou thank you Mr Speaker and hello
everybody I rise in support of Senate
Bill 333 as amended by the committee the
uh the full bill is on the um the State
Building Code and I think we have
unanimous agreement we certainly did in
the committee supporting the building
code change House Bill 1252 was a bill
that passed this house uh several weeks
ago on a unanimous almost unanimous
Voice vote and it went to the Senate the
house and it's it's on a study committee
for Native American issues many of you
in this house have watched as we've
tried to address some of the problems
happening in the Native American
Community it took two years the first
year all measures failed and this year
this house as I said passed it almost
unanimously when it got to the Senate
it's the first time the Senate has heard
it and the Senate's position was
basically go back and try to work things
out amongst yourselves which we've been
trying to do uh my colleague my esteemed
colleague who just spoke was given some
misinformation there um the bureau on
Indian Affairs there is no federal
recognition for aanac in the United
States there is federal recognition of
two bands of abanaki in Canada and they
are not connected to the bands in New
Hampshire in any way other than some
relationship things and then uh there
are four bands of abanaki recognized by
the state of veran and no abanaki
recognized by the state of New Hampshire
which is part of what we'll study with
the studville so I would like uh to
thank you all for your support in voting
yes on OT PA as the committee voted 13-2
thank
you the motion before us is the
amendment 1855
H are you ready for the question on the
amendment division a division has been
[Music]
the motion before us
is 18 the amendment
1885 H is say division vote chair
recognizes representative Carol Maguire
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this study committee was passed by
the house on a Voice vote and if I know
that the commission on on Native
American Affairs has has been
dysfunctional for years and needs some
button the motion before us is amendment
H1 1885
H this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
nay motion
fails question is now on aop
pass are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I oppose
majority of the committee on executive
departments and administration to which
was referred Senate Bill 440 an act
relative to the board of Optometry and
the regulation of Optometry we consider
the same report the with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill are to pass with Amendment s of
committee the minority of the committee
have considered the same being unable
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation Bill be referred for
interim study sen of Diane sht for the
committee for what reason does a member
rise uh to make a motion State your
motion to table the bill
motion division a division has been
requested members take your seats on the
the motion before us to table Senate
Bill 440 this is a division vote I'll be
an order
chair recognized representative Nagel
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if and I know that despite the
edaa vote and despite what seems like
Decades of testimony there are six
passionate speakers here ready to debate
indicating that the issues raised by
this bill are far from settled and if I
know that the current bill is lacking
and MTI stakeholder support and the
proposed floor amendment has not been
subject to either legislative or
stakeholder review and if I know that
the primary basis for this bill was to
increase rural access to Eye Care yet
studies in both Kentucky and Oklahoma
after much more permissive legislation
was passed failed to show any such
increase and furthermore if I know that
optometrists are not medical doctors are
considered primary eye care doctors and
they receive minimal General Medical
Education and no formal Surgical educ
ation yet this bill would allow them to
perform several surgical procedures and
furthermore if I know that based on
testimony from two professors of
Optometry in Kentucky and Oklahoma the
only schools which actually allow
students to perform these procedures on
live patients confirmed that
optometrists received grossly inadequate
training in the proposed surgical
procedures which has not even come close
to meeting the standards of sural
Representative this is a parliamentary
in I know all right almost done training
for similar procedures established for
MDS Do's podiatrists veterinarians or
dentists and finally this would if I
know that this would create a dramatic
paradigm shift and who is allowed surg
to perform surgery then I would come to
the conclusion that this bill is not
even close to being ready for prime time
and would support the table motion thank
you chair recognized representative Cod
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I may
quote my friend from Charlestown we've
got some some stuff to talk about and if
I know that polary procedures should be
short and when they're too long we need
to talk about these things would I not
vote no against the tabling motion thank
you the motion before us is the table
Senate Bill
440 this say div Vision vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposer press the red button
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attendance stay the
vote
224 voting a 177 137 voting a Senate
the committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 134
order an act relative to disability
pensions for Public Safety employees who
are victims of violence consider the
same report the same with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
sen of Joe Sweeney for the
committee bills on second reading open
to further Amendment representative
motion thank you Mr Speaker members I
rise today to support this floor
Amendment and it's because we have
passed this same the the bill that this
floor Amendment duplicates twice through
this house this term it's not often that
we pass a bill through this chamber two
times in one term to get the other body
to do some action with it but the fact
that we have shows that this this body
which is closer to the people has shown
that the people of New Hampshire want
something
done the other body likes to call itself
the upper chamber which implies that
that body is elevated above the house
but that's not
true there's a reason why all our
salaries are the same in the state
constitution we're co-equal
branches we're not employees that need
to be reigned in by upper management
because their our ideas are those of the
people and they may not align with them
I ask you to pass this amendment to try
to restore some balance and send a
message balance between the two Chambers
by pushing this discussion and
compromise
forward please help me send this message
I ask for your support on this floor
Amendment and let's give them another
time one more chance to get it right
thank
you the motion before us is floor
Amendment
2098 h
this are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
than
the motion before us is floor Amendment
298 H this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative L long for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker if I know that the underlying
bill is of uh utmost importance uh and
should remain clean uh and if I further
know that currently uh civil action can
be taken for falsifying uh suspected
abuse or neglect
claims uh then when I press the uh red
Speaker you I recognize representative
Spain for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know know that this bill is
something that we have agreed on
multiple times the bill that this
amendment covers and that we know if I
further know that the people of New
Hampshire want some action taken to make
sure that uh their children are not
weaponized against them from anybody for
any
reason and Mr Speaker if I further know
that we need to send a message that we
are willing to negotiate and discuss
things with the other chamber but we
don't want to be dismissed out of hand
would I now push the green button and
pass this
amendment the motion before us is
amendment 2098 H this a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
represent
while members president an opportunity
vote 160 voting aay 2011 voting aay the
motion
fails bills on second reading open to
further floor Amendment further
Amendment representative Penza offers
floor Amendment 2131 h recognized to
motion thank you Mr Speaker I thought I
had a couple more minutes to prepare but
um I think I know this pretty
well this amendment is based upon on HP
1620 which passed our house and
environmental committee um
unanimously based upon working
bipartisanly for the citizens of New
Hampshire the house support was
351 to only seven in
opposition on the Senate side when our
bill went over it was
55 to
7 there is no question right now that we
are actually good in New Hampshire for
another 25 to 30 years at
minimum and that's not including the
reduction um the the reduction plans
that we have in way in in place um based
upon our Solid Waste
goals right now we are asking for a
pause until July of
2028 because the rules are in shambles
we have a full lee8 crisis right now
happening in
Bethlehem um every ton of waste that's
going north at least a ton of leech
eight is going south to Manchester to
conquer to Franklin and we just
discovered recently that we are actually
taking
in millions of um millions of tons most
likely at this point of leech eight from
a landfill in
Vermont there are so many things that we
have to do
and I want everyone to know that this is
not going to sacrifice the underlying
Bill we're hoping that this is going to
send a message that maybe we could go to
a committee of conference and actually
finally have the New Hampshire citizens
voices be heard the one piece I wanted
to say the Senate received over 1,800
phone calls these are people from all
over New Hampshire saying we need
I will end
with de's own data makes it clear that
the earliest need for an additional
landfill capacity is
2034 when our bill first came out we had
2031 we worked on a part partisan way
and we made it to
2028 and based on the recent testimony
from Waste Management which is in
Rochester regarding their potential
expansion we have more than enough
capacity to over
2050 we really need all sides to come
together at this point to protect the
health and the well-being of New
Hampshire citizens and the New Hampshire
advantage and our environment we don't
want we don't want this to be our
thank you Mr
Speaker just this week the Department of
Environmental Services held a public
hearing on a proposed landfill sighting
rules this update to the rules happens
important environmental
experts concern conc ered
citizens and legislators from both sides
of the
aisle voiced their
opposition unanimously to the rules
update because they are weaker than the
previous rules they are slightly better
than the previous rules but they have
become
weakened in the different variations
that our commit was
shown they started at a certain point
again therefore because the Draft rules
do not provide the protections Granite
Staters need and deserve we are asking
for your support on this
amendment we must not go forward with a
new landfill
in the state of New Hampshire until the
protections are in place a community of
our
constituents up and down the state are
depending on
us industry can always gain a seat at
the
table we need to be that seat at the
table for the granite Staters whose land
and water are in increasingly saturated
with contaminants and
P this chamber has spoken with one voice
in defense of our
environment and public
health our friends on the other side of
the
wall need to hear loudly and clearly
that Granite Staters demand action on
this
issue we need to have a conversation on
the merits of the issue Environmental
Protection is a core small D Democratic
principle please support this amendment
Speaker the motion before us is floor
Amendment 2131
H are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
eyes have it floor amendment is
adopted
the the motion before us now is all to
pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay no eyes hav it committee report is
majority committee on finance to which
was referred Senate Bill 217 FNA an act
establishing a rural underserved Area
Educator incentive program for higher
education making an appropriation
therefore considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate sen of Tracy emrich for the
majority of the committee chair
recognizes representative Harkin
Phillips oh I'm sorry wait a minute uh
the minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable agree
with the majority report the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
represent Mary Harkin Phillips for the
minority of the committee chair
recognized representative Harkin
Phillips thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I rise today in
opposition to the itl motion for
sb217 this bill establishes a rural and
underserved Area Educator incentive
program administered by the Department
of
Education this bill is intended to
combat teacher shortages in New
Hampshire's most remote and economically
disadvantaged public school districts
frankly the problem is one of
Recruitment and
Retention New Hampshire's most
vulnerable districts cannot afford to
raise teacher salaries to a more
competitive level because their local
budgets are property their local budgets
and property taxes are already St
strained this leads to teaching
positions left unfilled or qualified
professionals departing after a short
time for more attractive salaries in
urban or Suburban
districts one Statewide education
satisfaction survey cites the high cost
of degree attainment and the burden of
school loans as significant factors
playing into teacher dissatisfaction
and leading causes to leave the
profession this bill this program will
serve to recruit Educators to begin
their employment in places like rural
Coos County and the grants will also
help retain these same Educators to stay
with a modest salary boost here's how it
works eligible new graduates existing
Educators and second career teachers in
these districts can apply for up to four
years of increasing Grant payments from
$1,500 in the first year to $4,500 in
the fourth year if the educator stays in
their district for those four years the
program has a potential total
accumulated value of $112,000 per
grantee the New Hampshire higher
education commission will use the
authorization within this bill to
develop rules and protocols for
determining the number of yearly Grant
Awards based on available
funding the program in this bill is
modeled after the successful Idaho
incentive program targeting rural
teacher shortages and is supported by
critical stakeholders like Nea New
Hampshire critics say that this program
is best left to negotiations for future
budgets but we know the teaching
shortage in New Hampshire's most Rural
and underserved areas need attention
today improvements on the shortages in
one corner of the state will assist to
relieve shortages in all corners of the
state that's why we can't afford to wait
on this critical program and that is why
the initial appropriation of $1 for the
fiscal year ending June 30th 2025 will
Propel the commission and the Department
of Education to begin rule making and to
build up the program while aspiring not
mandating more robust Appropriations in
future
Bia rest assured a vote for this bill
will leave the future funding control
within our future
legislature therefore Mr Speaker passage
of this bill is warranted given the near
zero fiscal impact the potential return
on future investment a house education
committee's unanimous bipartisan support
and this body's recent Voice vote to
approve the bill on consent Mr Speaker I
urge you to vote no on the itl motion so
that another more appropriate motion may
be made thank you Mr Speaker and I
Emerich thank you Mr Speaker I thank my
colleague for outlining the pro the
program it's an excellent
program however from a financial
standpoint what we're being asked to do
is to obligate a future
legislature so I I recommend the itl
because I don't think it's our position
is 12,000 I mean the program itself
allocates $112,000 per new teacher so
it's saying what we're going to spend
but it doesn't say how much it's going
to cost there was no fiscal note on this
bill so all we're doing is we're setting
up a debt for the future legislature so
support representative Granger has
requested a roll roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
us is a majority committee report of
inexperience to legislate on Senate Bill
217 Mr R call vote chair recognizes
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that Senate Bill 2117 was a bill that
was recommended by the T teacher
shortage commission and if I further
know our Northern and Rural communities
struggle to find teachers especially in
areas like math and science for their
classrooms would I now press the red
button so another motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker do I recognize
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the future costs
of this bill are not known and if I
further know that this body relies on
the finance committee for the match of
spending to the income or funds
available if I further know that this is
not the time to try an experimental
program that we have no data to judge
whether it would have the hope for
success or not would I now push the
green button to vote inexpedient to
legislate thank you the motion before us
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legislate to Senate Bill 217 this a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're post you
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
to vote El will attend to stay the
vote 184 voting a 174 voting aay
committee on finance to which was for
Senate Bill 311 FNA local act relative
to property tax offset for the town of
Hamstead making an appropriation there
four consider the same report the same
with the following Amendment a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment
of Jerry Stringham for the M
committee committee amendment is 18678
printed in house record 20 Page
38 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say
I oppose nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted the bill is on
second reading open to further Amendment
pres of Aer offers floor Amendment 2113
H it's in your seat Pockets Rec caniz to
Amendment uh thank you Mr
Speaker yes I'm up here to uh see if we
can uh actually pass a bill that we
amendment you know this is for cities
and towns and
counties what it's actually about is as
I mentioned before when I was up here is
to actually reim urse the towns and
cities and counties for
75% of the retirement costs for teachers
police and
fire it was actually passed uh pretty
handily uh just re you know by us just
recently so what I like to do is have
people consider it again it was
bipartisan support to get this passed
before then if we can pass it again uh
Guthrie thank you Mr Mr Speaker and
welcome to the early summer day uh I'm
here mainly as a selectman from Hamstead
this B this bill was originally to uh
compensate the town my town for the fact
that the state moved
into uh a small
Hospital uh and bought the land and
we're going to build a facility there
for mentally
ill uh and this had a real impact on our
town so this bill was important and I
won't go into that if if you've watched
a uh uh Communications particularly I
spoke on in the finance committee and
favor of this bill so this is an A bill
is very important to us and we would
like to have it clean however would you
believe I showed up uh at the session
this morning I'm feeling good about this
bill I wouldn't even have to speak about
it the chair the speaker would you know
say all those in favor and the way we go
uh there's no issue involved really here
uh it's doing the right thing and I find
out that is uh non
gerain I like that word non gerain uh
Bill attached to my to my bill and why
is
that I really don't know I been here for
a while and I can tell you that when we
get to the short Strokes like we are now
at the end of our session watch out for
non gerain
bills this uh bill is
uh article rather uh amend Amendment
rather has nothing to do with our
bill and I think the issue has been
discussed uh
previously uh in a uh previous bill with
negotiations uh with both the Senate and
the house and I would ask you to to uh
do the red button and get rid of this
gerain article so we can go forward
you the motion before us is the for
Amendment 2113 H are you ready for the
question on the amendment roll call has
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is floor Amendment
2113 H this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
pi the motion before us is the amendment
2113 H this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you press the green
button if your P press the red button
[Music]
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 177 voting aay 183 voting aay
motion
fails we now back to autop pass as
are you ready for the
question
who I heard a division from I heard a
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on Senate Bill 311 this say
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
[Music]
all members present had opportunity to
vote 3177 voting a 45 voting a committee
committee on finance doers referred
Senate Bill 337 FN an act relative to D
and lactation service provider
certification having considered the same
report the same with a recommendation to
Bill out the pass representive Karen eel
committee bills on second reading open
to further Amendment representative
Maguire Dan McGuire offers floor
22h it's in your seat
pockets and is recognized to speak to
his
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker the uh
this makes a one-word change to the bill
the bill currently has a sentence which
reads the office shall make every effort
to include racially and geographically
diverse community members and providers
Etc this changes the word racially to
culturally
there's two good reasons for that first
of all we already have laws and um a
Human Rights Commission that work hard
to make sure we don't discriminate
racially in employment so we shouldn't
be telling um the Departments to to
racially discriminate in in terms of
employment but also so originally I was
just going to ask to remove the word but
uh at the suggestion of the Department
of Health and Human
Services um I'm proposing that we change
it to the word culturally which is what
what they intend to do because in child
re
rearing um there may be cultural
differences um and therefore that should
be taken into account and also there may
be language differences among different
cultures and perhaps that should be
taken into account so it's a very simple
change it's enthus enthusiastically
supported um by the Department of Health
much the motion before us is Maguire
floor Amendment
2102 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I oppose nay the
eyes have it and the floor amendment is
adopted representative bills on second
reading open to further Amendment
representative Lon offers floor
Amendment
2083 H is recognize to speak to her
motion thank you Mr Speaker uh julas and
midwives play a very very important role
in bringing the new generation into this
world but with birth we need to also
address the trauma from sexual assault
that is why we have this amendment to
add the language of House Bill 378 378
is a bill that was passed on consent
that simply would have the Department of
Justice condense a 207 page document
they have about the rights of sexual
assault survivors into a one to two page
document done through the rulemaking
process so that people know their rights
there's actually already another one but
it's 40 pages it was hard for me to get
through and I wasn't just hadn't just
been assaulted this is critical because
if a woman is denied the ability to have
her rights to know what she can have in
a sexual assault kit what support she
can have and if she never gets to a sane
nurse she will carry that trauma forward
with her it Expresses in many different
ways and difficulty in childbirth is one
of them I have too many friends who ran
into challenges because that trauma that
had never been addressed came back
again we had been working diligently on
this language to address some concerns
in the other body I thought we were
moving forward to be able to to work
with the Attorney General's office and
come to a committee of conference to
come to some agreements on the language
because quite frankly both bodies have
had a lot of bills to do unfortunately
yesterday the other body decided to
indefinitely postpone this
bill they voted to indefinitely postpone
a bill to notify sexually assault sexual
assault survivors of their rights I
cannot imagine and I cannot fathom that
they still have the opportunity to
resend that and I would hope that they
do but sending this message that women
are important that survivors need to be
heard and they're not going to be told
to be sit down be quiet we know what's
best for you is critical so I ask for
your support in sending this message
that we support survivors and that this
body has an equal seat at the table
thank
you motion before us is floor Amendment
2083 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I
n division has for clarification this is
a division on clarification nobody in
nobody
out the motion force a clarification
vote on floor Amendment 2083 H if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
fails the question is now on ought to
pass as
you the motion before us is ought to
pass as amended on Senate Bill
337 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I I oppose
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred Senate Bill 352 FNA act
establishing an early detection cancer
screening pilot program for active and
retired firefighters considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation bill pass
with Amendment Senate Laura Toki for the
committee the amendment is 1
915h printed in house record 20 Pages 49
the CH Rec recognizes Ste Pearson to
speak on the amendment thank you Mr
Speaker I'll make this real quick
because I've had a number of colleagues
ask about the committee Amendment the
committee Amendment on this is good it
is necessary to tweak and fix a couple
of little errors that were made when
this was originally drafted I ask you to
please support the committee Amendment
thank
you the motion before us is committee
Amendment
915h are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose nay no the eyes have it the
committee amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor favor say I those
oppose nay the eyes have it committee
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred Senate Bill 355 FN act
relative to newborn screening
I will not try and butcher that word up
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Morin Mooney for the
committee the amendment is 1983 H
printed in house record 20 Pages 50
through 51 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I oppose nay the eyes have
it and the committee amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
without a pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I oppose nay the eyes have
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred Senate Bill 369 FNA an act
directing the office of professional
lure and certification to provide notice
of public meetings and an opportunity
for comment creating a new position
making an appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
a recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sen of Joe Sweeney for the
committee are you ready for the question
the motion before us is all to pass on
Senate Bill 369 FNA are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
am committee on finance to which was
referred S A bill 393 FN an act relative
to making an appropriation to the
Department of Environmental Services to
fund Regional drinking water
infrastructure having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment sen of Joe
Sweeney for the committee the amendment
is 1793 H printed in house record 20
page 55 are you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
I I those oppos nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now it's ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say
iOS n the eyes have it the committee
the committee on finance through which
was referred Senate Bill 396 FNA and act
relative to making an appropriation to
the culinary arts program at the Wilbur
H Palmer Regional Career and Technical
education center consider the same
report the same with the recommendation
the bill ought to pass senat Mary Heath
for the
committee representative Hall
offers floor Amendment 21358
and is recognized to speaker for
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker today I rise in support of
amendment
21358 the intent of this amendment is
simple to support families who are
vulnerable by providing greater access
to school meals for their
children Amendment 21358 accomplishes
two goals it raises the eligibility cap
for free School meals to 350% of the
federal poverty level and two it funds
the cost of providing these meals
through the existing Federal
reimbursement program combined with a
new state reimbursement program to be
financed through the education trust
fund it does not affect adequacy
grants currently as part of the federal
reimbursement program families whose
annual household income is up to 130% of
federal poverty received no cost School
meals and families whose annual houseold
household income is 130 to 185% of
poverty receive reduced cost meals with
this legislation the state reimbursement
program would cover the cost of meals up
to 350% of poverty not already paid for
by the federal government the 350%
eligibility cap as proposed in this
amendment for a family of four is about
$105,000 to put this into perspective
the median house so income in the state
of New Hampshire for adults 25 to 64 is
about
$108,000 so this amendment would support
those low to Middle inome families who
fall into the bottom 50% of New
Hampshire's median household
incomes years of research have shown
that School meals play a critical role
in a student's attendance well-being and
academic success a healthy diet can give
the child the energy to think work and
play School meals are as essential to
education as buses books computers or
the internet yet kids access to those
meals has been curtailed while many
families struggle to pay the bills
including dealing with the rising cost
of putting food on the table over half
of New Hampshire children reportedly
live in household with insufficient food
this amendment ensures that our most
needy Children and adolescents receive
at least one nutritious meal per day and
is a positive step toward ending
childhood hunger in New Hampshire this
vote is our opportunity to commit to
assisting Granite State families in
reducing food insecurity which is
associated with problems with childhood
language development social interactions
chronic illnesses mental health
disorders and
obesity our neighboring states of
Vermont Maine and Massachusetts have all
passed permanent Universal meals
legislation House Bill 1212 identical to
this amendment passed this body three
months three months ago on a 193 to 175
bipartisan vote let's once again vote to
assist low to middle-income families and
to ensure that New Hampshire kids are
not hungry at least not during their
school day it's not only the right thing
to do it's the least we can do please
join me in pressing the green button so
that we can feed the kids thank you Mr
Speaker and I would like to request a
division vote chair recognized represent
of
lad thank you Mr
Speaker as a past school teacher in
grade four for the first four years and
then a school administrator for the
remaining roughly 40
years I've been in a number of
situations K through 4 K through 8
junior high school high school and yes
we have kids that come to school that
are not fed but schools take care of
that that right now they do that there
is no insecurity in regard to that
schools do step up to the plate teachers
often times step up to the plate and
help what this bill does we now provide
free reduced meals up to 185% of the
medium family
income and now we want to extend this to
350% of the family medium income which
is as been previously spoken to about
approximately
$105,000 for that family of four
right now we get reimbursement from the
federal government up to
185% we do not get any reimbursement
beyond that
number and so this the taxpayer the
local state taxpayers is going to have
to pick up this
burden roughly 160,000 students in our
state K through
12 using these numbers right here 60% of
that 160,000 kids are going to be
receiving reing this free
meal we're going to have to cough up
that money and we haven't spoken about
the revenue yet but the fiscal report
from the Department of Education says
somewhere between 50 and 75 million
do 50 to 75
million on top of this we often times
speak of local control we have 38
schools in this state
which do not involve themselves with the
lunch program or the breakfast program
they provide it
themselves now what they're going to
have to do if they're mandated to
provide this program the federal program
they're going to have to beef up their
kitchens they're going to have to hire
more personnel and there again there's a
local expense involved for those 38
schools who School boards are making
local decision we'll do this through a
contracted service or we'll do it
ourselves but we're not getting involved
with the feds so in conclusion I ask you
you representative Hall has requested a
division this will be a division vote
seats Harington has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
the motion before us is
Amendment 2131
35h this a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative woodst
Speaker colleagues if I know that the
information I just heard from the
chairman of the education committee is
in accurate today as it was when hb1
1212 came before and if I know because
the analytics show us that Maine and
Vermont provide Universal meals for $34
million not the 50 or 75 for one meal we
just heard quoted it was wrong then and
it's wrong now not his numbers doe
numbers and he is correct every single
School in this state every one of your
schools where you support and you
represent is in debt today on non-funded
meals from youngsters who have nothing
when they get there and the school
district is picking up some as they can
if they happen to be able to identify a
youngster but that means there's a lot
of other kids there a lot of students
not being fed now let me just imagine
this every one of you I presume today if
I know everyone here
order continue thank you if I know that
most everyone here today had the
opportunity to have breakfast and
probably could afford breakfast and I
know that everyone here today has the
opportunity to have a free meal as you
did last time 1212 came up but
youngsters who are getting up in the
morning at 6 a.m. going to school
without breakfast getting on a bus at
7:00 getting there at 7:30 and not
having a meal do not have that
opportunity and if I know that this
process will allow them to do
that in
conclusion if I know that we came here
for one purpose which was to make New
Hampshire Better academics sound
education makes New Hampshire better
then would you please press the green
button so we can get on with the
business that my good friend art Ellison
used to say and just feed the damn kids
thank you chair recognize ripson of Vlad
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this bill requires the
eligibility threshold for federal school
meal programs raises the level from from
185% of the median family income to
350% of the poverty level would require
State taxpayer funds to cover the
difference as no fidal reimbursement is
provided if I know the Department's
fiscal analysis the Department's fiscal
analysis on the bill estimates the total
cost of this program could be more than
50 million per year to provide a lunch
for 60% of the 160,000 students in New
Hampshire's public schools and lastly if
I know not all schools currently
participate in the national school lunch
program or breakfast program and this
bill does not require that they
participate however if pass the state
would be required to pay the cost and of
the meals for all students that qualify
even the current 38 schools that do not
participate in the school lunch or
breakfast programs would I then press
the red button thank
you the motion before us is floor
Amendment 2131 H this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 177 voting aay 185 voting aay the
motion
fails for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I'd like to request the last
record sor
the motion before us now is autop pass
on Senate Bill
396 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say i
iose
n the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted now yes Mr speaker now I'd like
to make that request the motion will
make to print the uh the prior debate in
objection we have a request on for a
roll call on this next bill uh there is
no debate representative Granger has
requested a roll call so is that
sufficiently seconded I I okay hopefully
get it done first the committee on
finance do refer Senate Bill 403 FN and
act relative to the new to to the Health
Care Workforce having considered the
same report the same with a
recommendation Bill ought to pass Mary
Jane walner for the
committee representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
motion before it's a to pass on Senate
Bill 403 FN this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
while members present have an
opportunity to vote house attendance St
the
vote 241 voting a 122 voting a the
adopted committee on finance to hisory
Senate Bill 404 FN an act relative to
expanding Child Care Professionals
eligibility for the child care
scholarship program consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation Bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senor Mary Jane
walner for the committee the amendment
is 1 19 21h printed in house record 20
Pages 56- 58 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I oppose nay the eyes have
it amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppos a
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred Senate Bill 406 FNA an act
making an appropriation to the
Department of Health and Human Services
to increase rates for shelter programs
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill out to pass with Amendment
s laor Toki for the committee the
amendment is 18 66h printed in house
record 20 Page 58 are you waiting for
the question on the amendment all those
in favor say i
iose
n the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the bill be the question before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay no the
am committee on finance which was
referred Senate Bill 409 FN act relative
to reimbursement for ambulance services
under the State Medicaid Pro Plan and
consider the same report the same with
the following Amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with
Amendment the amendment is
1862 printed in house record 20 Page 58
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose
nayay the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted representative
Stringham
offers floor Amendment
20268 it's in your seat
pockets and recognize Rec Stringham to
speak to his
Amendment thank you Mr speaker uh this
amendment adds the entire content of
House Bill
1593 to Senate Bill 409 uh for those of
you who don't remember 1593 was an
important bipartisan and
non-controversial disability Bill uh
passed twice in the house uh it was a
very limited uh uh uh bill as amended
and very impactful it temporarily
restores suddenly remov services from
the developmental disability waiver
program that recipients expected to
continue and then we're taken away
without notice in fact we plan to pay
half of them uh through the Medicaid DD
program uh the removed Services were
recreational Services uh that were
suddenly removed so House Bill 1593
allowed adults uh with limited means up
to $600 a year here to restore these
Services just for this bium and required
health and human services to generate a
report so that a suitable replacement
could be identified and implemented uh
with an next bium so the program totally
discontinues there as I said that bill
passed twice uh here on the house floor
uh on voice votes uh was uh favored in
Health and Human Services by a
17-3 uh vote and in financed by a 24 to1
vote uh before uh being gabbled through
on the on uh with voice votes in the
other chamber uh the content of this
bill has been supported the bill has
actually been amended five times now
with a non- gerine Amendment related to
hospital disproportionate share payments
which may not survive the legislative
process uh so um a vote Yes here will
support the will of both houses to
support this disability waiver
program uh and um uh you know W with or
without how uh that bill the original
Bill uh comes through so I'd ask you to
please shout loudly and clearly I on
this amendment as well as the 25 to
nothing supported underlying ambulance
you a division has been requested
members take your
the motion before us is floor Amendment
2026 H this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you'll press the red
[Music]
represent
Damon all members present have an
opportunity to vote house attendance St
210 voting a 152 voting a the amendment
is
adoped the motion before us now is ought
to pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay guys have it committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on finance to
which was referred Senate Bill 417 FN
relative out of home placements for
children having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation that the Bill
ought to pass with Amendment sen Jr for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation to Bill a to pass Senate
David priest for the minority of the
committee committee amendment is 1 19238
58-62 there is a debate on the amendment
thank you Mr
Speaker uh Senate Bill 417 uh went went
to finance with a unanimous vote from
children and family law and a decisive
house vote in lighted troubles with an
out ofate placement of a child in need
legislators of both parties went to work
on improving policy and procedure the
bill delineates various policies and
procedures to protect aest children and
provides the best possible care for them
that this amendment would put more
children at risk for us the finance uh
the committee's amendment changes
section 24 and six contrary to the
safety and wellbe of the child or
sibling to contrary to the welfare the
amendment will go against the primary
purpose of current statute 169 C2 the
mandatory reporting of suspected
instances of child abuse and neglect
which protects childr whose Life Health
and Welfare are endangered
the child's best interest shall be the
Court's primary consideration in all
proceedings under this chapter second
the finance committee Amendment changes
section three with regards to parental
Fitness hearings the amendment changes
the language of presumption of Fitness
to deem fit which is legal which is
legal language that would indicate a
finding it also changes the standard of
proof required from preponderance of the
evidence used through RSA 16 69c
including what is needed for dcyf to
remove a child from a parent to clear
and
convincing the uh bail the comparison to
the bail standard is entirely misleading
and misplaced as bill is a criminal in
nature and not addressed in RSA
169c uh finally the committee Amendment
changes in the amendment that would
probably cause potential danger to
children at risk is the change made to
Unique needs which is an incomplete
definition excluding essential factors
such as psychological and
educational uh needs if a def if a
definition of unique needs excluding the
clause and whether or not the parent is
adequately prepared to address those
needs which is essential to the safety
child the children and family law
committee worked with due
diligence and came up unanimously with
the best supporting the best interest of
the child and I urge you to oppose the
uh committee's Amendment thank you Mr
H thank you Mr Speaker good morning this
bill has to do with out of home
placements last year we found out about
a couple of kids who were shipped out of
state to Tennessee and were dreadfully
abused down there
there we need to do our best to make
sure we keep children in the state that
have been removed either from a home
that's abusing or neglecting them or
through some judicial process because
they had committed a crime either way we
need to find ways to keep them in the
state so we can address those K
children's needs
here the amendment before you makes some
critical changes to make this
happen the former speaker for Manchester
talked about well we're changing the
definitions relative to um when kids are
taken well it's not taken the chapter
we're impacting is for a parent not
choose sorry not charged with abuse or
neglect so we might have a divorced
couple where a mom or a dad ends up
being charged with abuse or neglect and
we want to get the child to the other
spouse as quick as
possible today's Law requires that other
spouse to go to the court and to demand
that they be seen as innocent no other
place in our statutes do we require
someone to prove their innocence before
they can be a DAT
again the amendment carefully crafts
language to address this it keeps in
place necessary things like looking for
The Unique needs of the child relative
to physical mental emotional or medical
needs it makes sure that if there is a
concern about this not parent not
charged that DC CF or another agency can
interrupt the process and go to the
court and make a complaint this is the
way we treat everybody except for this
narrow F set of set of cases where we
have a parent who is absent for some
period of time and that could have been
for a court order and they are
asked the they have to now go demand
their innocence with the
court the bill also adds some additional
staff to dcyf we heard test testimony in
and and this is true of all the
Amendments we heard testimony that that
quantity of staff may be excessive so
that's something that longterm needs to
be addressed it is my understanding that
if this bill is passed today with this
amendment the likelihood is it's going
to a committee of conference to work out
details with the Senate with that said I
would ask that you would support
Amendment
19238 and I ask for a roll call thank
you
representative P has asked for a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
the motion before us is Amendment 1 1923
H this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognized representative priest
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
Amendment
2024 1923 H goes against the primary
purpose of the current
statute 169
c-2 the mandatory report rep in of
suspected instances of child abuse and
neglect this protects children whose
lives Health and Welfare are in danger
and is contrary to the child's best
interest if I know that the amendment
changes the standat proof required by
preponderance of evidence used
throughout the existing RSA
169c including what is needed to remove
a child from a parent to clear and con
and
convincing this comparison to Bell
standards is misleading and misplaced as
bill is criminal in nature and not
addressed in
RSA
169c a civil procedure meant to protect
children again this would put more
children at risk and if I know that this
amendment would probably cause potential
danger to Children at Risk by changing
the definition of unique
needs excluding the clause and whether
or not a parent is adequately prepared
to address those needs
which is essential to the safety of that
child Harmony mcuny had unique
needs
representative the house will be in
order representative this is a
parliamentary
inquiry would I now press the red button
to aul's Amendment
d923 age so that a better motion can be
made and probably the lives of children
can be saved thank you chair recognize
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that some bills are put together in
haste and if I further suspect that this
bill impetus was we have to do something
about the boys abused in Tennessee if I
further know that all these previous
amendments still left loose ends that
the finance committee endeavored to fix
would I now support those thorough
efforts and push the green button to
you the motion before us is Amendment 1
19238 this is a roll call vote on the
amendment if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
while MERS president had an opportunity
vote 186 voting a 178 voting a the
adopted the motion before us now is a to
the question now is ought to pass as
amended are you ready for the
question representative H has requested
a roll call is that officially seconded
it is officially seconded this will be a
clear
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended this is going to be a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
represent
power all members present had
opportunity to vote house will attend to
361 voting yay three voting a committee
ch
for what reason doesn't member rise to
make a motion State your motion Mr
Speaker having voted on the prevailing
side for 417 I move to reconsider and
no 17 the question is on
reconsideration of SP
4177 I heard someone ask for a division
clear
the question is whether to reconsent
Senate Bill 417 and it's a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
[Music]
represent
down have all members presence had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the closely contested
vote 33 in the affirmative 325 in the
the majority of the committee on finance
to which was referred Senate Bill 453
FNA an act making an appropriation to
the Statewide voter registration system
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
representative Dan Maguire for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Karen able for the
minority of the committee questions on
the minority of the majority committee
report of inum study you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose
nay think the eyes have it and the
adopted the majority of the committee on
finance which was referred Senate Bill
450 5 FN an act relative to Medicaid
reimbursement rates for prosthetic and
orthotic devices having said the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Jerry Stringham for the
committee the question is on committee
Amendment 1958 H printed in house record
20 on page 69 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I all
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
Amendments adopted now the question
question is the majority committee
report Au to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay no
adopted the majority of the committee on
finance which was referred Senate Bill
456 FN an act relative to the state loan
repayment program for qualified nursing
professionals and making an
appropriation therefore and consider the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Laur Alki for the
majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Jess Edwards for the
minority of the committee representative
Edwards is recognized speak against the
committee
report uh thank you Mr Speaker I I'm
rising today to encourage an I vote
overturning the committee
recommendation I um this first came to
division 3 and I was uh in favor of it
initially because I care deeply about
patient care particularly in underserved
areas and having worked in health care
for over 45 years I really appreciate
what the nursing Community does for uh
our society uh but this bill did not
werewell on me as I started to think
about the testimony we heard we heard
that we would be spending
$300,000 in general funds to help six
people do what is called loan
forgiveness there is no loan forgiveness
there is a transfer of the loan debt
voluntarily taken by a person
transferred to the general public there
is no forgiveness there's just a debt
transfer um and so um I would I I
confirm the six by the way you're going
to hear much bigger numbers you're going
to hear as many as 17 or something but I
asked very specifically how many people
would be affected and there was no
ambiguity in the answer there's six
people
300,000 that's 50,000 each now to go
into an underserved area you're probably
going into a community where the median
income is only $50,000 and here the
state is going to grant that much money
to a single individual to go provide uh
critical and important care but this is
the kind of economic micromanagement
that really makes very bad policy over
the long run so I would uh I would
encourage you to support an
itl representative cherski is recognize
speak for the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker the state loan repayment program
or slurp has successfully worked in our
state for 25
years and is a program where medical
professionals can receive assistance
with their student loans if they commit
to a long-term contract working in
areas that are designated as
underserved using strict federal
guidelines that are based on population
metrics and the number of medical
providers in the
region overwhelmingly the participants
of this program end up in Coos County
which has a severe shortage of medical
provid
ERS s SP 456 appropriates an additional
$300,000 to slurp to be used exclusively
for nursing
professionals just imagine for a second
a young person graduating with a Nursing
degree from St anum's or Rivier
University in the southern part of the
state they may not even be considering
starting a career up north however this
nationally recognized program provides
an incentive of assistance in loan
repayments for them to work and live in
an area that desperately needs
them those who participate will agree to
a three-year contract they will work set
down
Roots provide care and connect with the
community starting their life there and
ideally settling there for the long term
being able to care for the people who
live
there in testimony we heard that this
bill could extend the program to six
full-time professionals currently on a
wait list and adding just those
providers to this region could add
approximately
25,000 patient visits to an area where
receiving Medical Care is a real
challenge the bill also directs the
department to provide a report with
recommendations on if it's feasible
to expand the program in future years I
ask that you please support this
bipartisan bill that will attract
nursing professionals to settle and work
in underserved areas like Coos County
please press the green button and I ask
for a division vote thank you Mr
Speaker questions on the majority
committee report about to pass this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
clear
questions on the majority committee
report about to pass on Senate Bill 456
representative Edwards is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry uh thank you Mr Speaker if I
knew that this bill would cut six people
$50,000
checks so that they could go serve in a
community where the median income is
essentially
$50,000 would I recognize that to be a
gross example of poor economic
micromanagement by the government and
vote
red representative stringham's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that uh the slurp is a proven program
for providing Medical medical
professionals for over 25 years to
underserved areas if I know the program
is currently out of funds and there is
documented need currently if I know that
this has um been particularly valuable
in Coos County where medical
professionals are scarce and if I know
that passing this bill will provide tens
of thousands of
additional visits for needed uh for
personal care uh with nurses provided by
this program would I please press the
green button uh for this bipartisan Bill
thank you very
much questions on the majority committee
report about about to pass Senate Bill
456 this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
[Music]
okay of all members pres had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 178 in the affirmative 182 and the
negative the motion fails representative
Edwards representative Edwards moves
inexpedient to legislate on Senate Bill
456 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those POs
committee on finance which was referred
Senate Bill 463 FN an act expanding
access to court appointed councel for CH
children in dependency proceedings
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill off to
pass with Amendment representative David
priest for committee the committee
amendment is 1 1971 h prined on house
record 20 on pages 70 to 72 questions on
the adoption of the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the Amendments adopted
now on to the main the majority
committee report of oop pass as amended
are you ready for that question all
those in favor say I I all those oppose
adopted for what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker having voting on the
prevailing side of Senate Bill 456 I
move reconsideration and urge the body
to vote now representative Sweeney moves
reconsideration on Senate Bill 456 this
will be a division vote members take
your
the question is whether to reconsider
Senate Bill 456 and this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
[Music]
of all members presence and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 174 in
the affirmative 186 and the negative
reconsideration fails for what reason
does the member rise thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side of Senate Bill 217 I
move reconsideration and urge the body
no 2 representative Sweeney moves
217 there it is you ready for the
question thought so this will be a
questions whether to reconsider Senate
Bill 2117 and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote the house will attend to the
state of the vote 177 in the affirmative
1:15
e
committee on Commerce and consumer
affairs which was referred Senate Bill
558 FN act relative to insurance
coverage for infantility treatments
protection from discrimination during
IVF treatments parental leave and
adoption consider the s report the same
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim
study Mr Speaker
for what reason does a member rise for a
motion Mr Speaker State your motion I
move to table Senate Bill 558 and I
request a division vote
please okay tabling motion has been
motion a division has been requested
members take your seats
division J
say
the motion before it is to table Senate
Bill
558 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative hunt for
parliamentary
short the motion before us is the table
Senate B
558 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
we're in the voting
while members president had an
opportunity to vote El will attend to
say to the vote
325 voting a 32 voting a should I bill
chair recognizes the clerk for a motion
Mr Speaker representative Gard moves
that all necessary house rules be so far
suspended as to allow late Drafting and
introduction of a bill relative to
allowing for members of the General
institution chair recognized
representative
speaker I bring this forward because I
was denied the ability to inspect and
tour the county jail in my county and
also the state prison unless I was
essentially put on a leash and brought
around with the director the head of the
director of the Department of
Corrections from Jean Graham now the
reason I'm bringing this forward I
understand this is the end of the
session everybody's trying to wrap
things up but I was just recently denied
from my County the ability to be a
religious volunteer as well as somebody
that was inside I think it's important
to talk to these inmates especially on
account of the fact that now we're on
the hook
for oh okay that were on the hook for
$38 million law uh settlement from the
YDC cases because quite frankly people
in this chamber did not visit these
facilities they did not talk to these
people and abuses went on for
decades the idea that we should trust
bureaucrats to watch other bureaucrats
is absurd we are the closest to the
people not appointed political
appointees I think that should be
self-evident from this NPR article May
15th the judge who oversaw a landmark
trial about New Hampshire's Youth
Detention Center has refused to discard
the $38 million verdict saying the
facilities leadership quote either knew
and didn't care or didn't care to learn
the truth quot end quote about endemic
physical and sexual abuse there are more
than 1100 lawsuits now
pending my concern is that we do not
know what's going on in these facilities
from the most basic to how inmates spend
their days to how the money is being
spent or pocketed and other things so I
put this bill forward well this
suspension of the rules cuz I think this
is important and I just received notice
from my County the other day otherwise I
would have put this in earlier the email
from the the state uh director of
Corrections was from November of last
year but I had assumed that going
through the religious aspect would be a
way to do it I just think it's important
to talk to these people there is no way
to really find out what's going inside
the facilities and then you could say oh
well they can write us yeah okay you
make what 10 cents an hour or something
it's and then the other concern is
people from the state prison have sent
emails to all of us I know at least you
received them you might have trashed
them but alleging that they were
terminated for raising
concerns so there is not an open channel
of
communication and with that I would hope
that you would support transparency in
our institutions because that's our job
and bureaucrats can't be trusted to
watch other bureaucrats those are the
two main talking points and I'm going to
gar ask for roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently second this
the motion before it's a suspension of
order this is going to be a roll call
vote the chair recognized representa
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
um as chair of the county delegation for
the county that the member was referring
to I can assure you all that if I know
that any member of our
delegation uh had the invitation to tour
Our House of Corrections and if I
further know that the member involved
probably was denied because of his
history uh would I now vote no on the
pending motion thank you
the motion before us is suspension of
the rules this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're imposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members presentent had an
opportunity to vote household tend to
vote 148 voting a 216 voting a the
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 476 FN that making
a capital appropriation to the
Department of Corrections toward the
placement replacement of the New
Hampshire State president for men
consider the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
committee offer her representative Harry
at goth offers Amendment 21538
in your seat
Pockets chair recognizes representative
haret
goth chair recognized representative
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker Speaker you may recognize this
amendment it's the bill that we passed a
few weeks
ago and it still does the same things
it's still takes nobody's gun rights
away
nobody it still takes nobody's gun
rights
away the person who would be affected by
this R this bill already lost their gun
rights the moment they were committed
involuntarily think about this for a
second and and seriously think about
this for a second you are brought to
court because you are mentally ill to
the point where you're dangerous you get
examined by your own doctor the court
orders you to be examined by another
doctor you get a lawyer the lawyer can
argue on your behalf and cross-examine
Witnesses against you after all that's
done a judge not a bureaucrat makes a
decision that you need to be committed
now not just for the the temporary exam
commitment but a full commitment for 30
days because the judge finds you to be a
danger to yourself or others you get
committed you're in there for 30 days
receiving mental treatment should you be
able to walk out the door across the
street and buy a weapon even though just
30 days ago you were committed because
you heard voices that said you should
kill
people that is exactly what happens if
you have if you have schizoph renia you
hear voices and sometimes they tell you
to hurt
people all we saying and this this
doesn't do anything but report that to
the federal Nick system now let's talk
about the Nick system where'd that come
from I'm old enough to remember the
Clinton
Administration in the Clinton
Administration there was something
called a waiting period a national
waiting period we all had to wait you
couldn't just go buy a gun you had to
wait so the NRA stepped up and said
listen that's over we're going to work
on legislation so that people can get
their firearms rights right away we
propose an instant background check
system that's where ncks came from it
came from the NRA
so they said what gets submitted by the
states is what gets
checked just recently the NRA came out
and said the system's only so good as
the information that gets put into
it what good is it if 99% of the state
except for us put that information in
there we submit felons we submit
restraining orders for some reason
Hampshire decided that people who are
dangerously mentally ill we not going to
submit it makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever at all just recently now I
saw an email from some group recently
that came out that said that this was
about a gun grab or some ridiculous
thing of course at the bottom of every
one of those emails is please send us
money but having said that oh yeah here
they are the National associations for
gun rights what do they have to say on
the subject well I went to their page
and said what are what's their position
on Mental Health it
says it shall be it says there has been
a consistent push to Grant agencies and
individuals the power to deem Americans
mentally defective thereby depriving
them of their constitutional rights
without due process mental health
restrictions on Firearms ownerships
which circumvent due due process are
unconstitutional what I just described
to you is due process you go to judge
you go to court you have an attorney you
can cross-examine you can present where
so their arguments are invalid what does
the NRA say the NRA says just recently
the systems only so good as what you put
into it and they Advocate here's what
they
said exactly word for word it's been the
NRA's longstanding position that those
who have been adjudicated as a danger to
themselves or others should not have
access to Firearms this wasn't 20 years
ago this was
2020 so if anyone in here is saying well
the gun groups are saying pay attention
because the gun groups change depending
on who's in charge but Nicks was founded
by the NRA and they believe it so as New
Hampshire citizens do we want to be able
to face people when someone does
something because we decided nope we're
just not going to do it even though all
the other states are doing it we're not
going to do it it makes no sense oh and
did I mention we're leaving hundreds of
millions of dollars on the table the
federal
government has established just recently
under a bill called The Fix Nick Bill a
fund to help States improve their
electronic uh criminal justice
Information Systems millions and
millions of dollars are dispersed to the
states except for New Hampshire because
when we don't submit this information
we're not eligible so do we walk away
from that and the danger to our fellow
citizens I don't think so I think that
we pass this one more time to send the
people across the on the other side of
the wall the message that we believe in
safety we believe in freedom but we also
believe that there are limits and we
you the motion before
us is amendment
21538 this is going to be a division
vote
members representative who request a
roll call is that officially seconded it
is officially seconded should be a roll
call
the motion before us is amendment 2153 H
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Roy for
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
oh thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill and this
amendment does not criminalize mental
health the people that are involved in
it have access to Due Process before any
of their rights are taken and
furthermore the bill itself doesn't take
rights but just reports the event that's
already occurred to the federal Micks
background check that the NRA
established and asked for would I now
press the green button to adopt this
amendment to further en Hampshire safety
to make us access to Federal grant money
and to ensure that we are consistent
with the rest of the country thank you
chair recognize represent AO for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker I apologize
for stepping ahead early if I know that
the underlying bill has to do with
setting aside money so we can design am
Men's prison and that by adding an
amendment we put in in Jeopardy the
underlying Bill if I know that the
language of the amendment says
notwithstanding any other hold on I got
to not withstanding any other provision
of the law including a requirement of a
closed hearing and a file under RSA 135
that's relative to mental health
records if I further know further know
that these people people potentially
might be in danger of suicide but this
will cause the unintended consequence of
them not seeking the mental health
treatment they need and furthermore if I
know that every gun group in the state
and many national ones stood opposed
would I now vote against the adoption of
21 53h thank
you motion before us is amendment 2153 H
so roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button you're
opposed you'll press a red button voting
[Music]
Mar all members pres have opportunity to
vote 202 voting a 165 voting a me is
adopted motion before us now was a pass
as
amended are you ready for the
requested representative finny is
the motion before us is a to pass as
amended on Senate Bill 476 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
while members present at an opportunity
vote 212 voting a 155 voting a committee
report is
adopted
okay for what reason is a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr Speaker
seats the house will be in recess for
minutes
e
second
know
the house will come to
order chair recognize the representative
motion thank you Mr Speaker I move to
represent uh reprimand representative
becoming recognize you Mr representative
one at a time one at a time
speaker we we have a motion as to one
representative do we know if there's
another motion coming afterwards and
could the speaker explain about
reprimands and how they
work yes there will be another motion
thank
you I'd
like chair recognize represent Ville
thank you Mr
Speaker for those of you that don't know
me I am the reprimanded representative
verl from Rockingham second district
representing Auburn candier and
Deerfield and when yall wagged your
me no I take that back yeah I I I I trct
the statement thank you I appreciate the
calling out so I I was reprimanded and I
viewed it is nothing more than a finger
wag and that's all it is there's nothing
more there's nothing less my only regret
is I didn't ask for a copy you know
presentable for for public display can
we stop the nonsense vote this down move
on and get along with the business that
we have there is zero value in any of us
reprimanding any of us can we just vote
speak
I
yes what reason does the member rise Mr
Speaker to make a motion of a higher
priority State your motion I move to
table the motion on the floor and return
back to the house business I would ask
everybody to support the table motion
thank
you the motion is in order the motion
before us is the
table the motion to
reprimand are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I those opposed n the eyes have it the
thank you Mr Speaker chair recognizes
representative Mella thank you Mr
Speaker I'm I move to uh represent uh
reprimand representative
Cel uh for conduct on becoming thank you
Mr
Speaker for what reason does a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker to move make a
motion of a higher PR priority State
your motion I move to table the motion
to se representative to to reprimand the
you a division has been requested
the motion before us is to table the
motion to
reprimand this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
divine all members president an
opportunity to vote house attendant stay
to the
fa major committee on finance to which
was referred Senate Bill 499 FN act
relative to reduction of hunger for
children and older adults and people
with disabilities consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and recommendation that the
bill a to pass with Amendment s of jrh
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment and
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment s la tki for the minority
of the committee the majority amendment
is 1
19578 printed in house record 20 Pages
24 chair recognizes representative
wolf here is a debate on the
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker the amendment CH chair recognize
wolf Mr Speaker and members of this
house I rise today to oppose Amendment
1957 to SB
499 Amendment
1957 would remove the necessary funding
required for New Hampshire's
participation in the summer EBT program
summer EBT is a federally funded program
that would bring in over 4 A5 million
Federal doll each year for feeding
hungry kids during the
summer many children depend on School
meals but come summer they don't have
access to them summer EBT programs would
con connect these children to the
nutrition that they need when school is
not in session the startup cost for
implementing EBT is about a million
dollars in the first year however the
recurring cost to the state is very
small about $ 265,000
this
$265,000 annual investment would allow
New Hampshire to unlock $4 and5 million
dollar per year to feed over
37,000 kids the 4 and A5 million would
be directly invested into our economy
every year being spent at local grocery
stores farmers markets farms and other
small business it's a win-win feed
hungry children and stimulate our
economies and if we don't get the money
from the feds we're not obligated to pay
it so if we don't invest the money over
37,000 kids will go hungry every summer
the state will leave 4 and A5 million
federal dollars on the table New
Hampshire taxpayers currently contribute
a lot more to Washington than we receive
back back we should seize any
opportunity we have to make a smart
modest investment to increase the
state's federal revenue and invest in
New Hampshire's future the return on
investment has a massive upside and the
risk is none it's a smart business for
New Hampshire I urge you to reject
Amendment
1957 and to support an alternative
Amendment 1975
1917 excuse me which will include the
necessary funding for the state to
implement the EBT
program 1957 does not please join me in
voting
against 1957 so we can consider the new
Amendment and invest in the granite
state Working Families and most of all
and hungry kids feeding kids is well
worth any investment that we can make
thank you and I request a division
torki thank you Mr
Speaker this amendment does two things
one thing is good and the other is
nowhere near good enough which is why I
oppose it the good part that we agree on
makes it easier for seniors and people
with disabilities to access the
supplemental nutritional nutrition
assistance program the part that is
deficient is the section which
appropriates $50,000 for DHHS to develop
a plan to possibly Implement a summer
EBT program sometime in the
future we know that food insecurity has
a negative effect on children's
development can prevent children from
reaching their full physical cognitive
and psychosocial potential and that
these lasting effects can follow them
well into adulthood in fact poverty and
the food insecurity that results from it
is one of the leading adverse childhood
experiences that leads to Chronic health
problems mental illness and substance
misuse we also know that summer is the
time when children from low-income
families are most food insecure because
they cannot eat their breakfast and
lunch at school through the free and
reduced school lunch program if we are
able to implement a summer EBT program
each qualifying child would receive $40
a month on an EBT card for families to
buy food helping to bridge the gap in
their summertime grocery budgets to be
clear the EBT program EBT card is for
food not liquor cigarettes or non-f food
items we know based on current
enrollment that
37,325 children from low income families
would qualify for the program if it was
signed into law today
the majority Amendment appears to be a
step towards implementing the program
but I want to be clear if this amendment
passes these children will receive no
assistance in 2024 and absolutely no
guarantee of any assistance in 2025
either this is our window to act get the
program set up for the Future these kids
who qualify come from families with
incomes below 185% of the federal
poverty y level this means for a single
working parent with one child their
household makes less than
$38,000 for a family of four less than
58,000 for families in this lower income
bracket the rise in cost of things like
housing child care and utilities has
made it increasingly difficult to meet
basic needs like food the sponsor of
this amendment stated in our executive
session that he completely guessed when
picking the appropriation there was no
input from the Department and the amount
is just a fraction of what the
department stated is needed to build out
a plan for successful
implementation by comparison the
alternative minority Amendment which
will be introduced next contains a
detailed and transparent cost breakdown
directly from the Department on what is
needed to set up the program and start
getting resources to those who need it
making these initial Investments to get
the program going will allow us to
leverage at least $4.5 million in
federal money which will come back to
our state to be spent at our local
stores by not participating in this
program and leaving this money our money
our federal tax dollars on the table it
will simply go to children in other
states and New Hampshire children will
go without please vote no on this
amendment so an alternative amendment
can be brought forward and we can
discuss implementing a program to feed
hungry kids now thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues I rise
in favor of the committee amendment to
Senate Bill
499 it's numbered
1957 h on page 73 of the House
calendar the committee Amendment
replaces the Omnibus Bill that came to
house finance directly without going to
education or health human services
policy
committees the bill with this amendment
would become effective on passage and
does two
things first it appropriates a onetime
setup cost of
$37,500 to the Department of Health and
Human Services to implement the elderly
simplified application project with in
the supplemental nutrition assistance
program this important and much needed
change to law will allow the elderly and
people with disabilities to file every
three years rather than annually for the
food stamp
program
second it allocates
$50,000 to the Department of Health and
Human Services for creating a requ
request for proposal soliciting bids and
developing and and implementing a plan
the key word there is plan and that is
the huge difference between this
amendment and the Alternatives that wish
to be brought
forward this amendment is
realistic and it's Frugal in its
approach to a new and very expansive
program the alternatives are too fast
too
soon the house finance committee is
charged with examining and recommending
public
funds the majority agrees that this
amendment is a reasonable alternative to
the Omnibus Bill sent to us from the
other body please join the majority of
the committee and vote green to adopt
the committee Amendment 19
57h to Senate Bill
you this will be a division vote members
very
the motion before us is uh Amendment
1957 H this is going to be a division
vote chair recognizes representative
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
majority Amendment addresses only one
small part of this important bill to
reduce childhood and elderly hunger
and if I know that now is the time to
move forward and apply for the summer
EBT program so that it will be in place
for the summer of 209 of
2025 the summer EBT program will provide
up to $4.5 million of federal funds to
New Hampshire's lowest income
families and if I know that the minority
has an amendment which will imp
Implement both the elderly simplified
application and the summer EBT program
for children would I now vote no on this
amendment so that a more comprehensive
amendment can be brought forward please
push the red
button chair recognize representative H
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
the bill came over from the Senate with
12 million
in Appropriations or an estimate but
only funded less than $500,000 of that
leaving the house to find the difference
if I know that the house looked through
the various portions of this bill and
determined one was worth funding
directly and one was worth looking at
and investigating and
funding if I know that the total cost
was $887,000 to do both of those items
which would be fit within this year's
budget would I now vote Yes on Amendment
1957 each thank you
the motion before us is amendment 1957 H
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press the red button
[Music]
repr w president had an opportunity to
vote 182 voting a 185 voting a the
amendment
fails bills on second reading open to
further
Amendment Amendment 1
[Music]
917h printed in house record 20 Pages 75
74- 75
Mooney thank you Mr Speaker and good
afternoon once more to my colleagues I
Rise now against the committee amendment
to Senate bill or the amendment rather
to Senate Bill 499 it's numbered 19
1917 h on page 74 of your house calendar
now this amendment does maintain the
much needed one-time setup cost of
$37,500 to the Department of Health and
Human Services to implement the elderly
simplified application project within
snap and also that's to help uh the
elderly and those with disabilities to
file every three years rather than
annually for the food stamp program that
is very important and I think the whole
finance committee thought so because it
is in both amendments proposed to you
today however this amendment number
1917 H overall spends too much too soon
on a new federal summer Electronics
benefit transfer program for children
that cannot start this summer
now this amendment also puts a temporary
program in place initially but then
requires additional funds the following
year I'm going to break down the
expenditures in this
amendment
$143,000 for personnel costs to the
Department of Health and Human
Services
$55,000 for funding Systems and
Technology in the first
667,000
for funding Systems and Technology in
the second
year the transactional fees for
82,500 each summer for the next two
years a $10,000 fee for one time time
setup costs and then a
$25,000 cost for
funding
Outreach it was mentioned that federal
funds are available but the maximum
federal funding amount is conditional on
all recipients of free and reduced lunch
participating the
total is too much right now for a new
program and the federal funding is too
indefinite to rely on the bottom line is
this amendment is Not Practical and it
is not Frugal in its approach during an
off budget year the majority of the
house finance committee agrees that a
program of this size of this cost cannot
be rushed or overspent upon and this
this amendment does both please join the
majority of the committee and vote red
on this amendment number
1917 H thank you for your attention do a
member yield a questions no member does
torki thank you Mr
Speaker the previous debate outlined
many the details so I'll be brief
Amendment 1917 h on page 74 of your
calendar directs the department to
participate in the federal summer EBT
program and the elderly simplified
application for SNAP I'd like to be
clear that the bipartisan bill that came
to us with the unanimous vote from the
other side was far more expansive than
what we have today this amendment
removes all sections related to the
Department of Education and deals with
only two programs under the direction of
DHHS the majority of the $1.1 million
appropriation will be for the one-time
startup costs and once summer EBT and
the simplified applications are up and
running there will be minimal
administrative cost to keep the program
going yes because the effective date is
July 1 a program for summer food
assistance can't start and be fully
functioning on July
2 however the benefits that are
designated for 2024 will still come into
our state they will just be delayed and
arrive in early
fall and with the system up and running
we will be ready to go as intended for
the 2025
year we already heard $45 million doll
will come into our state with the
program and it's estimated to have an
economic imp impa equivalent of $6.7 to8
million not only is it good for our
economy but it's also good for our
kids getting assistance to food insecure
families in the summer months can be the
difference for kids as they grow learn
and become positive contributing members
adults if it's too much and too fast to
do
it then when
now is the time to do it please vote Yes
on this amendment and I ask for a
Speaker sen H requests a roll call is
that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
aon's
the motion before us is Amendment 1
917h a roll call vote chair recognize
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the program that we're trying to
implement here is already covered under
various social welfare programs if I
know that the Civic organizations in the
state the churches and some of the other
already if I know there's places like
the New Hampshire food bank that are
available that don't force people who
are already living on the edge to fund
somebody else's
breakfast would I now vote no on the
adoption of 17 1917
H chair recognize from sen of Wallner
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
amendment before us will implement the
elderly simplified
application which will enable elderly
persons to be more easily able to apply
for the supplemental nutrition
assistance program a program which
provides food assistance to older adults
and people with disabilities and if I
know that the amendment also directs the
Department of Health and Human Services
to
provide the in the federal to provide
application for the federal summer EBT
program the program provides $40 per
month per child for the summer months
when children are not receiving meals at
school if I know these are the children
these children who are eligible are the
children who receive free meals at
Public
Schools would I now know that these are
also some of the lowest income families
in our state if I know the benefits paid
to the families in the summer EBT
program are 100% federally funded and
the cost of the administration of the
program is split between the federal
government and the state would I now
member is giving a parliamentary inquiry
at this
done the motion before
917h this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
repr
represent all members president had an
opportunity to vote house attend to stay
the
vote 192 voting a 178 voting a the
adopted bills on second reading open to
further Amendment representative Aaron
offers floor Amendment
motion thank you Mr Speaker
good afternoon
colleagues I rise today to ask you for
support on this floor Amendment we're
interested in helping people you can't
on this um floor amendment is the exact
same language from hb1
1466 that was passed unanimously out of
house
Edna and house finance and then
body uh okay
um the language creates a statutory
vehicle for the state to financially
help a municipality right after a
natural
disaster no such Authority exists now
and no appropriation of funds are
necessary now I don't know about you but
I don't appreciate this important bill
being dismissed or ignored by the other
body and I was told that our position on
assisting municipalities in their time
of need didn't matter and that despite
not needing any money appropriated at
this time and since it's an off-budget
year this would have to wait I don't
think we should wait when we can do this
now and I think we need to send the
message to the other body that we are
serious about disaster relief and they
should be
too please join me in supporting this
floor Amendment and helping out our
towns in their time of need and Mr
Speaker I request a division
vote the division has been requested
the motion before us is Flor Amendment
2125 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos you press the red button
[Music]
all members presid had an opportunity to
vote 189 voting a 181 voting a the
amendment is adopted we're now on autop
amended representative Earth is waving
off representative
teski representative teski waves off and
asks for a division
seats Zen Aran has requested a roller
call is that official ly
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
vote the motion before us is ought to
pass as amended on Senate Bill 499 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button you're
opposed you'll press the red button
all members present at an opportunity to
vote house will attend to stay of the
vote 235 voting a 136 voting a comme
on
the majority of the committee on finance
to which was referred Senate Bill 553 FN
an act requiring that funds held by the
public deposit investment pool be
invested in New Hampshire having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill Op toas
with Amendment representative Joe
Sweeney for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative Gerald Griffin for the
minority of the committee the question
is on the amendment
19108 printed in house record 20 on page
95 representative Griffin Griffin is
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker this amendment does
two
things one it reduces the percentage of
the public deposit in investment pool
that is subject to the underlying Bill
and two it sets a Sunset date for that
bill in in in so doing I believe it a a
knowledges that the bill is
overreaching and
unnecessary but the amendment is better
than the underlying bill and I ask you
to please support the amendment so we
can move on and defeat the amended bill
motion the question is on Amendment
19108 you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the Amendments adopted now we're on to
the main motion of a to pass with
Amendment representative bogert is
recognized speak against the committee
report
good afternoon Mr speaker thank you I
rise in opposition to this bill as this
is not a Republican bill this is not a
democratic bill this is a municipal bill
which will take money from the
municipalities now what they're asking
you to do is to take a percentage of
money and put it into a State Bank
Chartered bank or whatever so that it's
invested inside the return on this
investment which everybody here
understands what the return on your
personal investment is you rely on that
return I can speak for lonia because
I've been in good conversations with our
finance director and what this does is
it lowers the threshold of return on
that investment if you looked at your
own savings accounts from all the banks
that you've got your money tied up in
can you honestly answer you're getting
the best return for your money I think
not but in this case they can invest it
in this PP fund and what that enables
them to do is get a larger return on
their investment now speaking for
$200,000 now that's not chump change and
what happens is that money helps to
offset the property tax that is required
of the residents to pay for the city
budget this also rolls into County
budgets where the county budget it's
going to be tied into this same type of
format so if they're investing in a p
dip then they're going to start to lose
some of the money that is involved in
this a city and a town no matter which
size it is they only have limited
resources for
revenue and if you take away another way
they could take advantage of improving a
revenue Source then there's only one way
to make up the money it's automatically
going to come from the
taxpayer now I don't know that that
makes sound business sense to sit and
say you can only invest in what we're
going to tell you to invest in from a
state level and why a local city our
town our municipal ality whichever you
want to look at it can make that choice
on how they want to take their fund
balance and invest it for the best of
their
constituents and that's what it's all
about not the bankers
Association this is strictly property
tax business so please oppose this bill
in every way shape or form the amendment
made a bad Bill a little better but the
bill is still bad thank
you representative Griffin's recognized
report thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I rise today to speak
to you not only as a fellow
legislator but also as a former
Municipal treasurer and a person with
quite extensive Financial
history the public deposit investment
pool was created some 30 years ago and
it has been a great
success its goal has always been to
uptain the best return available with
safe
investments in that time it has never
lost money and has grown to nearly 700
million invested by our state our County
and our
municipalities s SP 553 seeks to change
the pools investment policy in two
ways Investments must be deposited in
New Hampshire Banks and they must be
ensured or
collateralized the committee's amendment
we just passed significantly softens
those
requirements by reducing that percentage
affected by the
bill uh from 100% to
30% the amendment also sets a Sunset
date for the bill and in so doing it
acknowledges that the bill is
overreaching damaging and
unnecessary all of the
uses of the pool that we heard from
oppose the law due to the likely
deterioration of their investment
returns and as we all just heard from
the last speaker those returns are used
to lower the property tax in our
municipalities and lowering the tax in
our
counties in
2023 the law was amended to remove the
trust from the banking commissioner's
office and place it under the oversight
of our very capable State
Treasurer in committee she testified
that the trust was not broken and was
working well for its
uses she also testified that in the few
months since she took over and her
office have been working with the
trust's advisory committees reviewing
and developing policies and objectives
for the
pool the legisl should let that process
play out without
mandating a geographical constraint on
that process that limits the pool's
returns please support the Judgment of
your County city and town
treasurers by pressing the red button
and defeating this motion so a motion of
interim study can be made for this bill
as written and it can go to a peaceful
quiet
death thank you representative grass's
report thank you Mr Speaker I write in
in opposition to HB 553 I think that the
last two speakers that you've had have
pretty much laid out most of the facts
dealing with this the public investment
pool has been around for quite a while
it's an option for communities again
it's an option for communities they can
invest in their local banks or they can
invest in the pool one of the things
that that people don't think of is a lot
of the bigger cities you have your own
investment advisors we have a finance
director in Rochester and we invest most
of our money in local
banks but smaller communities don't have
that
opportunity some of you know me you know
that I worked in a number of small
communities here in the state of New
Hampshire and I've worked with a number
of the administrators public
administrators Town administrators
County administrators as well
their position has been that they have
not been involved in this
process this bill sort of was fast
tracked on the other side of the wall
got over here and the administrators in
fact I was sitting home on a Sunday
afternoon and I get a call from a Town
Administrator saying are you aware of
this bill and I said not
really what is this doing and he says
I'm not
sure but it doesn't sound good because
right now we are investing in the pool
and we are making good money we have
never lost a dime never lost a not even
a penny never lost a penny in the public
investment pool and it currently they're
earning a better rate that they can get
elsewhere and that's something that
communities when we take a look at the
bill as
amended you you may hear and discussion
about the original bill was how this was
all this money was going to be
reinvested back into the state of New
Hampshire and be a benefit to the
communities and the dollar the way it
gets transferred in and out of the state
or in within the state it's going to
make more revenues for the state well
the bill has been amended and it
actually does very little because it
says we shall
aspire to 30% it doesn't say we shall
have 30% invested in the state but we
shall aspire to
30% again as you heard from the previous
speaker the banking commissioner said
that she has been working with the
Advisory board about this bill you
about the trust and what they would like
to do with this pool is they would like
to take more time and work on it and
have the and develop the policy and
develop the rules for Investments
they're working on that right now this
bill would throw that all
out when I spoke to the treasurer when
this amendment came up and we were told
this is a compromise amendment that we
have it was a compromise between the
bankers and the treasurer
the investors were never involved nobody
asked the town administrators the
finance directors the trust fund
administrators the county administrators
those people who are responsible for our
local communities and counties were
never involved in any negotiations on
amendment I'm asking you to stand with
your local communities right now and
vote no on this and allow us to send
this to inim St study so that we can
take a good look at this bill we can
work with the town administrators and
Trust advisers and and any everyone else
in the state that invest in this pool to
do what is best for the taxpayers in our
community thank
you representative sweene is recognized
report thank you Mr
Speaker a as everyone else has said
already Senate Bill 553 came to us in
house Finance radically different than
what is presented to us today after we
adopted the committee Amendment Senate
Bill 553 the title there is requiring
that funds held by the public investment
public deposit investment pool be
invested in New Hampshire however the
amendment that we adopted uh on a Voice
vote just minutes ago really does
rewrite the bill to make it a
legislative intent that we encourage the
investment advisor to invest 30% of the
fund Fund in insured or collateralized
Investments currently 0 of the public
deposit investment pool is insured or
collateralized zero dollars of the
public deposit investment pool of all of
our taxpayer dollars in the various
communities that are investing in it
zero of those dollars are invested in
the state of New Hampshire this
amendment the the bill that is now been
amended provides a vehicle for us to
move that direction but the One
requirement in the bill still is to
achieve the highest attainable stable
rating for local taxpayer dollars in
that investment pool so while we are
encouraging more of the pool to be
insured and collateralized to be in the
state of New Hampshire we are requiring
that highest attainable rating still be
pursued as the main priority for the
public deposit investment pool otherwise
known as Peta obviously there was a lot
of work put into this bill uh there was
a a lot of in uh Insight from the
stakeholders that were involved we tried
to make the bill work I believe we
achieved that uh and we put into a
sunset of 2030 so that a future
legislature can see what changes to the
public deposit investment pool that
mouthful of a term I've now said 20
times in one speech we can see what
changes are made to that investment pool
over the next seven years and make and a
future legislature can make further
adjustments go back to the way things
are today
but the biggest takeaway from this bill
is if this bill passes and is signed
into law by the governor the public
deposit investment pool is the same as
it is today as it will be tomorrow it
does not it it creates that legislative
intent to encourage more insured or
collateralized investments in the state
of New Hampshire uh and I would urge you
to vote with the bipartisan 16 to9
committee recommendation to pass the
bill as amended thank
you a division votes been requested this
will be a division vote members take
your
the question is a majority committee
report about to pass with
Amendment representative Dan Maguire is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
upsets policy that has worked
beautifully for over 30 years and
invested funds has risen to nearly $700
million and if I know that our
municipalities counties and school
districts rely on the interest from the
fund to pay their expenses and moderate
property
taxes if I know that no actual user of
this fund wants it to
change and finally if I know that 30% of
a bad idea is still a bad
idea would I now press the red button
and defeat this ought to pass motion
thank you Mr
Speaker representative camri is
inquiry
now
berer you're not making a motion are you
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that Senate Bill 553 as amended
simply encourages insured or
collateralized funds in the public
deposit investment pool be invested in
the state of New Hampshire would I now
vote the green button to send this bill
back to the lovely body on the other
side of the wall thank you the questions
on the majority committee report have
about to pass with Amendment this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 176 in
the affirmative 190 in negative the
motion fails representative Griffin
moves what representative Griffin moves
inexpedient to legislate interim study
interim study fair enough representative
Griffin moves interim study are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose
you
the majority of the committee on finance
to which was referred Senate Bill 567 FN
and act directing the commissioner of
the Department of Health and Human
Services to compile a report on the
availability of mil
prone and miso prol hope I got that
close having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative J Edwards for
the majority of the committee the
minority of
[Music]
that
yeah so there's no yelling I don't like
being yelled at if somebody has a
legitimate point of order which is when
we are not following our own rules or
procedures then you can come down to the
well and state your point of order when
I'm done reading the bill
in having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Laura
cherski for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise for a motion Mr
Speaker St your motion I move to lay
House Bill 567 on the table and I
request to division vote ABS Weber moves
to lay Senate Bill 567 on the table this
will be a division vote members take
your
the question is whether to lay Senate
Bill 567 on the table this is a division
vote representative Simpsons recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
another abortion debate would be helpful
for us to clear be clear about what's at
stake in New Hampshire because of the
Supreme Court case on medication
abortion but that our day has already
felt long would I now press the green
button to table this
bill members should be in their seats
she a little too late the motion is to
lay Senate Bill 567 on the table it's a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
represent
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 302 in
the affirmative 54 in the negatives 567
table the majority the committee on
finance to which is referred Senate Bill
591 FNA an act modifying definitions
claims procedures and funding relative
to the relating to the Youth Development
Center settlement fund and claims
Administration having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment in the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Dan Maguire for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Mary Jane walner for the
minority of the committee the amendment
is 1911 H printed in house record 20 on
98 representative eel is recognized
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker this bill was brought forward
after extensive negotiations and
agreement between the attorney general
and attorney attorneys representing
hundreds of survivors of childhood abuse
at the Youth Development Center the bill
makes numerous changes in claims
procedures definitions and scope of
conduct covered under the administrative
process the bill was very C carefully
crafted by the Attorney General the fund
administrator and claimants
Council this amendment deletes from the
legislation the ability of the state
treasurer with with the approval of the
joint fiscal committee and the governor
and councel to issue Bonds in order to
meet the state's obligation if
additional funds are needed that is
adequate assurance that the decision to
bond would be well
founded the amendment came to the
committee at the executive session with
no further input and no one had really
seen it before it came and there was no
consultation with the attorney general
about the effect of the deletion of the
ability to bond and what uh effect it
would have on the settlement fund and
the carefully crafted negotiations with
the claimant Council we really should
not be hampering with the attorney
general or the state's ability to do its
best in this unbelievably challenging
situation this amendment should not be
approved by this body especially in of
the criminal justice committee's 20 to0
recommendation of ought to pass on SP
591 the committee made no changes to the
bill as it came from the other body
please vote no on this amendment and let
this incredibly important bill moved
quickly to the governor's desk as it
should Mr Speaker I request a division
vote thank
you representative Dan Maguire is
recognized to speak on the amendment
thank you Mr
Speaker this is a 20page bill that
modifies the YDC settlement Fund in
various ways we heard in committee that
the total amount of the settlement that
the state is going to be obligated to
pay is roughly
$750
million 500 million of that to victims
and 250 million to their
attorneys the Bill itself has us pay
this on the installment plan we will be
obligated to pay $75 million per year
essentially for the next
decade um we have already allocated $100
million to the fund um of that 85
million have been spent so that leaves
15 million for next year this bill
allocates another 60 so that's our our
75 million to carry us through the end
of this bium through next
July a year from
July the only dispute on this bill
between the majority and the minority is
over this amendment this amendment
removes one paragraph from the
bill that
paragraph says that we may borrow our
commitment by paying victims in
installments we are already borrowing
the bulk of this money and paying the
victims 5% interest while we pay them
off to borrow further our annual
installment is not the kind of uh
Financial
shenanigans that should take place in
conquered that's something more suitable
DC debt is great for capital projects
but it is not good for annual
expenses such as this
one and specifically to the point of
discussing this change with the attorney
general I did following our hearing
speak to the attorney Assistant Attorney
General um who who oversees the
settlement Fund in this particular
case and this will not upset the
agreements that they have had with the
other side the main purpose of this bill
is to encourage the claimants to use the
settlement process get us out of court
as as much as possible and pay them off
on a schedule that the state can
afford but
to but to pile debt on top of debt is
simply wrong let's pay our way as we go
and remove further borrowing from this
Bill thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1911 H this is a division vote
the questions on the adoption of
H representative lean's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr uh
speaker so Mr Speaker I'm not sure where
Shenanigans are coming from and the
suggestions that we just heard but this
bill came to us from the Senate after
careful consideration and consultation
and support of the New Hampshire
attorney
general as you also heard this bill
passed out of the criminals Justice and
Public Safety Committee by a vote of 20
to
zero and this last minute Amendment did
the
approach be ready to tell me what got
violated Mr Speaker I don't think you
violated anything is this supposed to be
a pi it is supposed to be a pi I didn't
hear if I know I didn't hear anything
like that
I'm sure representative lean will be
more diligent to that as he goes forward
thank you very much Mr
Speaker and finally Mr Speaker again if
I know that this last minute Amendment
did not come to division one of the full
finance committee for a review and
consultation with the attorney general
wouldn't I vote no Mr Speaker so this
bill could come back without this
another point of order I violate the
rules every time there's a pi by not
answering their
questions representative wer is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry by
the way well done representative gadner
that was a proper point of order
class thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that Appropriations bills are sent to
the finance committee because of our
devotion to balancing the budget and
fitting the demands to the supply then
would I now support the amendment
because it supports the time honored
mechanisms where borrowing is mainly
used for capital projects and continuing
expenses are managed through cash flow
please press the green button thank
you the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1911 H this is a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the vote 187 in
the affirmative 173 and the negative the
Amendments adopted
now we're on the majority committee
report of ought to pass as amended are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on finance
which is referred Senate Bill 596 FN an
act relative to the definition of
disability or special needs under the
child care scholarship program having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Jess
Edwards for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass represent Mary Jane walner
for the minority of the
up got it the committee amendment is
1933 H printed on house record 20 on
represent walner is recognized speak
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker in contrast to the majority
position on this bill and this amendment
um it does not create a new program but
instead expands an existing initiative
in the child care scholarship program to
address the growing Gap in access to
child care that children with
disabilities are facing the Child
Development Bureau at the Department of
Health and Human Services already has
rules govering this program making the
need for a study committee
unnecessary the committee heard
testimony that this program is
underutilized because formal diagnosis
in very young children is difficult and
lengthy the minority recognizes the
immediate need to ensure young children
with disabilities have the same access
to child care as their
peers Senate Bill
596 will allow for the use of
Developmental screening tools to
identify to identify the special needs
of young children in child care these
screening tools will provide valuable
information and resources to the child
care provider as they care for and meet
the needs of these young children the
Child Development Bureau which is best
equipped to choose screening tools and
information about Services provided to
the children will develop the rules
around the expansion of the program a
study committee is not needed to do this
work there are existing federal funds
available to support the expansion
initiative and please vote no on the
majority Amendment and um move to
forward this bill back to the Senate
uh and forward with a providing
important care to our youngest children
who have disabilities please push the
red
button per Edwards has recognized speak
amendment uh thank you Mr Speaker um I
Rise to uh advocate for the study Comm
committee the amendment being um 2024
1933 H the study committee uh is is
appropriate because uh the majority
believes that the expansion of this
program is being rushed it was initially
a late bill from the Senate it it it got
filed after normal hours then it went to
our education committee out a committee
that was an 11 to n vote so it wasn't an
overwhelming vote there and when it got
to uh division three uh we we took
testimony and what we found out is that
the reality of what this bill would do
is different from what The Advocates say
it would do The Advocates are very uh
much interested in getting the extra
$100 a month per student or not per
student per kid into the child care
setting um and that's and that's B
basically the purpose of this bill is to
get the extra $100 a month per kid into
the child care setting now how do they
do that well they
untether um the state from the current
definitions of who's eligible and
instead kick it over to say kids who um
uh are showing signs that in the future
they make maybe uh developmentally
disabled would now
qualify uh in order to make that
determination rather than relying on a
definition they're relying on a an
assessment test that has not been
selected there are numerous assessment
tests that could be selected but there's
nothing in the criteria to say which
assessment tool would be used there's
nothing in the legislation that says who
ought to be um qualified to conduct the
assessment right now it's left very
gener generically to say or any other
licensed professional that opens the
door to a problem the problem is that um
in a in a child care setting you can
have licensed individuals who are giving
the assessment test with the idea that
if the assessment test says one thing
they'll get an extra $100 a month um and
in the corporate world we have this
thing called segregation of duties where
the people who are making the decisions
about finances aren't the ones who are
going to benefit from it these kind of
assessment tools should be independent
of the beneficiary or the recipient of
the $100 that's just common sense also
more common sense an assessment tool
like this ought to be conducted by a
master's qualified individual I don't
know that the education committee
considered that point but it is
important that an assessment like this
be done properly by a professionally
trained uh and and qualified person at a
at a master's
level once the uh assessment is done
properly then that $100 will flow to the
child care setting for additional uh
fees and there's nothing in the bill to
say what we'll get for that
$100 the proponents of the Bill say oh
all this great stuff will happen we're
going to hire more people we're going to
provide more training but there's
absolutely nothing in the uh bill that
requires that so we would be going on
the on trust and um it it's it's
probably something that we ought to be
more careful about because there's no
way to measure the success of this
program other than did we spend more
money because there are no performance
metrics set up in it so so for the these
reasons this should go to a study
committee so that we can do it right for
those of you who are worried about the
timing of the money that would flow the
extra $100 a month this would basically
represent a six-month delay in the the
funding starting but if we if we take
the time and that we do it right um the
the money will go take care of the kids
and also do it in a way in which the
legislature can be assured that the
extra money that's going going in is
going to actually come back with some
kind of achievable measurable output the
achievable measurable output is
completely missing from this bill and
therefore I recommend uh you press green
and um and send this to a study
committee thank
you the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1933 H are you ready for the
questionis a division's been requested
members take your
seats
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1933
H representative Stringham is recognized
seats thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that children with
disabilities face complex care needs for
the and the need is growing for the
disabled uh to locate child care
services and if I know a study committee
is not necessary as the program already
exists and this change is supported and
vetted and a reasonable differential
payment for these special needs is
specified and items like which
assessment int instrument to use is not
a critical issue if I know expanding
access to child care for those with
special needs has a palpable Financial
benefit to the
state because of our critical need for a
broader Workforce and those that canine
Child Care are more likely to work if I
know without this
bill workers who happen to be a parent
to a disabled child will be much more
likely to stay
home so would I vote no on the committee
amendment to form a study committee
which would delay arrival of federal
money and delay delay access for this
group of needy individuals so that
another OTP motion can be made thank you
for considering it representative
Edwards is recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry uh thank you Mr Speaker if if I
know that segregation of d duties is the
standard normal way in which uh wise
businesses avoid fraud waste and abuse
potential and that the way this bill is
set up that uh possibility exists
because the people that could do the
assessment or the people that would
receive money from the assessment and
that if I knew that there were no
performance metrics to say what is going
to be happening for the kid in exchange
for the additional money all we know
that additional money will go into the
child care system we if we know that
there's nothing in there to assure
performance or measurables then would I
go ahead and send this to a subcommittee
or a study committee so that we can
resolve these things and that we can
confidently spend money in a wise way in
a way that's most likely to actually
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 1933 H this is a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
have all members present have the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 180 in the affirmative 182 in the
negative the amendment
fails Bill still on second reading and
open to yet further amendments so
representative luno moves floor
Amendment 21158
which can be found in your seat Pockets
he's not offering you're not not offer
thank
you okay so the question is now on a to
pass so the question now is on ought to
pass are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I somebody called for a division all
right we'll do it should already be in
w
the question is on the motion of V to
pass on Senate Bill 596 this division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
[Music]
did
not have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the
vote 181 in the affirmative 182 in the
negative the motion fails for what
reason does the member rise Mr Speaker I
move inexpedient to legislate on Senate
Bill 596 moves what now I
table going to make a motion to table
and for what reason does this member
rise Mr Speaker I make a motion to table
Senate Bill 596 represent Wilhelm moves
to table Senate Bill
596 are you ready for the
that this will be a division vote
members are ready all in their seats
find
you
the question is whether they Senate Bill
596 on the table there's a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
[Music]
have all members present had yet another
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 182 in the affirmative 183 in the
negative tbling fails now we're back to
representative Sweeny's motion of in
expedient to legislate
somebody want to yell division because
it's what yeah thank you because that's
what we're going to do everyone's
already in their seats so let's just do
this the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on Senate Bill
596 and this is a division vote if
you're in favor of that press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
represent
represent have all members present had
an opportunity to vote the house 10 of
the state of the
vote 187 in the affirmative 178 in the
for what reason does a member rise thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker having voting
on the prevailing side on Senate Bill
596 I move reconsideration and urge the
body to vote
no repr Sweeney moves reconsideration on
Senate Bill 596 are you ready for the
question division this will be a
the question is whether to
reconsider Senate Bill 596 if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
all righty hopefully the last will see
of this Senate the house will attend to
the state of the vote 177 in the
affirmative 188 and the negative
the committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 604 FNA an act
providing a death benefit for a New
Hampshire hospital security officer
killed in the line of duty having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Gerald Griffin
for the committee the bill is on second
reading and open a further Amendment
representative Dan Maguire offers
Amendment 1938 printed in house record
speak thank you Mr Speaker this
amendment is on the very last page of
your
calendar Chief hos was tragically killed
last last
November while working as a security
officer at New Hampshire hospital we
already have a law which pays families
of police officers firefighters and some
others
$100,000 when their loved one is killed
in the line of
duty that law is
flawed because the list of those who
qualify does not include security
officers like
him this amendment corrects that
oversight and add security officers to
the list while of course continuing to
pay the benefit by name to the uh Chief
H's
family if God forbid one of our own
State House security officers was to be
killed protecting us wouldn't we want
their family to get this
benefit of course we would right and
would we want their family to have to
wait 8 months for a special Bill to be
written passed and signed into law of
course
not when people lose a family bread
winner their need is
acute first member will suspend for a
second really
noisy serious topic let's give it the
respect it deserves and hear the member
continue thank you Mr
Speaker when people lose a family bread
winner their need is acute let's pass
this amendment and add um security
officer uh to the list of those who
would benefit and make sure that the
families of those security officers will
at least not have to deal with immediate
financial needs
on top of their grief thank you Mr
Speaker the question is on the adoption
of amendment
1938 you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those opposed
nay no the eyes have it and the
Amendments
adopted we are now on to the main motion
of ought to pass as amended on Senate
Bill 604 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
committee on fishing game and Marine
Resources to which was referred Senate
Bill 503 act relative to requiring a
criminal background check when applying
for a fishing game license consider the
same report the same with a
recommendation to Bill a to pass pres of
committee bills on second reading open
to further Amendment
representative Spain offers
Amendment
1770 H printed in house record 20 Page
Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker members I once again rise to
support a floor amendment that I hope
you will all support with
me again we've passed this bill that
that the amendment covers two times
through this body and put to the other
side of the
body the last time it went to the other
side of the body we made changes here
that they said were critical to them to
pass it over there we made sure that
this would not apply to anyone under
18 and we passed it with more support
than
previously we removed brass knuckles
blackjacks and slungshot from
criminalized weapons for a small portion
of the state when we we know that
they're legal for anybody with a hunting
and fishing license or who works in law
enforcement or is an emergency EMS
driver and several other classifications
where it's okay for you to carry them
but it's not okay for everyone else we
leveled the playing field for anyone
that was over
18 but even though we made the changes
that they
requested they still said they were
going to ENT and study it and they said
no so again I'm telling you that this
amendment is more than a single bill
body again I'm going to
request that we do what we've done two
times before and send this amendment
back over for reconsideration on the
other side because it makes sense it
follows our Second
Amendment it allows for people to carry
self-defense objects that I mean are are
no different than what we've already
Declassified in fact less harmful than
uh Firearms knives of any length
swords tasers pepper spray all that's
legal for anyone over 18 but we're going
to sell them that they can't carry
something like this so we've made the
changes they requested we're limiting it
to only those that are over 18 and I'm
going to ask you to please help me
support this amendment and send it back
over there again thank you thank
Muse thank you Mr
Speaker currently carrying or possessing
these weapons with the intent to sell
them is a misdemeanor in New Hampshire
and with very good reason these are
weapons used by aggressors to intimidate
terrorize and to brutally attack their
victims the injur Ines caused by these
weapons can be devastating in addition
to inflicting concussions and potential
brain damage these weapons can fracture
skulls break bones destroy teeth and
cause wounds that require dozens of
stitches and plastic surgery to fix if a
doctor in fact can fix them at all the
bottom line is that if we remove the
current prohibition we might be making a
few more of these weapons available to
so-called average citizens but we'd also
be making the these weapons more
attractive and more available to Street
criminals and Thugs who can and will use
them to intimidate coerce and to assault
their victims as well as to injure
police officers in the performance of
their
duties at a time when many of us claim
to be working hard to come up with ways
to enhance the safety of our communities
the one thing we should not do is pass a
needless Amendment opposed by the New
Hampshire Chiefs of Police Association
that would instantly make our
communities our schools our bars and our
public gathering places measurably less
safe Mr Speaker please join me in
pushing the red button to defeat this
unneeded amendment thank you does a
member yield the
questions does a member yield the
questions do I yield the qu do you yield
the
yield the motion before us now is
amendment
H division has been requested
members who requested the roll
seconded it is sufficiently
seconded members take your seats this
vote
e
the motion before us is for is amendment
17708 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds members need to be in your
seats
do
[Music]
represent
all members presun to vote house will
vote 183 voting a 181 voting a amendment
is
adopted representative MC Williams
office floor Amendment 1
1905h printed in house record 20 Pages
75-
76 the chair recognizes representative
MC
Williams thank you Mr
Speaker this bipartisan Amendment adds
House Bill 1400 which you may recall was
the one residential unit one parking
space Bill to Senate Bill 503 this body
has already passed the same language in
House Bill 1400 on our consent calendar
by unanimous Voice vote unfor
fortunately the body on the other side
had has added several unrelated non-gain
amendments that may jeopardize that bill
I ask for your vote in support of adding
this parking amendment to Senate Bill
503 to let the body on the other side of
the wall know that our house supports
fixing parking issues still in order to
build more housing across the granite
state and Mr Speaker I ask for a
division vote thank
you the motion before us is amendment 1
1905h a division has been requested
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1905h this is a division vote chair
recognized representative MC Williams
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this body has already passed the
language in this amendment in House Bill
1400 and if I know that this is a good
bill that addresses parking issues in
the state in order for us to build more
housing AC across the granite state in
the midst of a housing emergency would I
then press the green button yes to
support this amendment thank you the
motion before us is floor Amendment 1
1905h this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press a red button
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
262 voting a 104 voting a the amendment
is
amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I close
n eyes haven't committee report is
adopted
majority committee on hton home services
majority committee on Health and Human
Service hey Affairs to which was
referred Senate Bill 402 an act relative
to allowing pharmacist to admit
influenza co9 and other FDA licensed
vaccines without explicit approval from
the general court consider the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation the
bill ought to pass with Amendment G
Merchant for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Senate Amica
lay on for the minority of the
committee committee amendment is
181 printed in house record 20 Pages 55-
56 are you ready for the question on
Amendment
1810 H are you ready for the question
n you eyes have it and the committee
amendment is adopted bills on second
reading open to floor of the amendment
speak thank you Mr Speaker there were
several very important bills that this
body passed um they were around
recordkeeping in child care centers and
vaccinations um when we considered this
in our body we looked at all the data
all the information and we looked into
the validity of the statements made in
committee unfortunately the other body
heard from some people who had a
particular interest and decided that the
bill should not move forward therefore
we have added House Bill 1231 in this
amendment in order to send it back so
that we can reduce the burden on our
child care centers this amendment also
takes um House Bill 1194 which is
relative to the definition of Comm
non-communicable disease as we are
looking at these vaccinations and
looking at more of this process we need
to talk about whether or not vaccines
for for anything that is not actually
communicable person to person should be
within the definition when you're
talking about something that doesn't
spread person to person there is no
public health benefit this body already
stated it that way however when there
was a discussion in the other body there
was conflicting information presented um
there had been some testimony um on one
of these bills where a a where somebody
from the government made one statement
and then they provided data that was
different in committee um this needs
further attention so it's very important
that we attach this and F and I ask for
your support there are three important
bills I think it's worthwhile and it
should resolve any objections to the
underlying bill should we pass this
floor Amendment so I ask that you vote
in favor of this amendment thank you
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker up until
the last few bills we were doing a
attaching different bills to the
important policies that are under
discussion and if you believe as I
do that having a clean vote on a clean
bill is is a much better way to pass
laws than
playing the same games that the other
place is likely to
play um I hope you will reconsider these
bills in addition these are not like
some of the bills that we've adopted
where everybody was in agreement uh
there's considerable reason not to adopt
first the change in definition of a
non-communicable disease because it
removes infectious diseases other than
tetanus if they're not transmitted
personto person and we all know that
there are infectious diseases in
addition to tetanus which can be
transmitted person to not personto
person but through a vector like a tick
or a vector like a mosquito and that
those diseases are moving closer to us
all the time so this is not an advisable
step to take the second one removes the
requirement of immunization records at
child care agencies which means that
parents will be unable to get the
aggregated
data that enable each parent to choose
What Child Care Agency they want their
kid to be that in accordance with their
preferences for their family so it
removes parental
choice and the final issue is the data
sharing provision which
again
uh is another bill that
expands expends
$107,000 for personnel and $80,000
for system upgrades that we could be
using for other things so with all of
that I hope you will let us pass a clean
bill with the amendment that we adopted
that makes the bill much better and go
on to hear about that Amendment because
the administration of RSV vaccines to
small
children is really important and the
amendment that we just passed narrowed
the bill down to just that so kindly
vote against the amendment by pressing
button the motion before us is floor
Amendment
H and our division has been requested
seats
motion before us is floor Amendment
2067 this is a division vote chair
recognize her absent of L on for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this floor Amendment would add
House Bill 1213 relative to the
immunization requirements for child care
agencies House Bill 1194 relative to the
definition of non-communicable disease
and House Bill 1669 relative to the
redistricting data sharing through the
state immunization registry to a bill
that simply allows a little bit more
flexibility in which vaccines
pharmacists are able to administer and
not to the RSV bill which we will be
hearing later if I knew that Mr Speaker
would I press the green button so that
we can make sure that the more important
policy issues continue forward on this
bill which is just a minor change to
Pharmacy laws thank you chair recognize
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Mr Speaker if I
believe if you believe as I do that we
should be letting the policy in this
bill stand by itself because we know
that the other considerations have all
been rejected by the other body would I
vote no so we can send them a bill with
the appropriate Amendment which you have
all just approved thank you
motion before us is floor Amendment 2067
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you press the red button
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote 177 voting a 185 voting a the
amendment faes we're now on to Auto pass
as
Amendment chair recognizes
I had lime disease for over 20
years I couldn't speak read do math I
couldn't tolerate light or sound
eventually I couldn't even get out of
bed to use the bathroom without my
husband carrying me I almost
died the
CDC had convened a committee to study
treatment the disease was studied by
many doctors but the report was written
by only two these two stated that two
weeks of antibiotics was all that was
needed and lime was cured in spite of
the objections of the other doct s on
the committee who said this didn't take
into consideration the people with
chronic
lime the report was released the
recommendation was made and doctors who
treated lime patients for more than two
weeks with antibiotics lost their
licenses for not following CDC
recommendations doctors were afraid many
stopped treating lime patients others
I had been treated with antibiotics for
two weeks many times didn't cure my
lime it made me feel a little better for
a little while but I slowly got worse
and worse and I finally found a natural
path who wasn't under the thumb of the
CDC and wasn't worried about losing her
license it took three years of
antibiotic and herbal cocktails but I
was finally cured of lime 3 years is
considerably long longer than the CDC
recommendation of two
weeks the CDC has shown that they are
not
trustworthy many of you in this room or
your friends and family have had to deal
with line you know the struggles to get
appropriate
treatment why would you pass this bill
to further trust the
CDC we shouldn't be trusting them to do
our job there are 424 of us between us
we have a wide variety of experiences
knowledge expertise and wisdom in
addition we know many experts in many
fields including virology and Immunology
whom we can call upon for advice do not
discount our ability to make the proper
decision when it comes to vaccines
please vote itl on this dangerous
legislation thank you chair recognize
Perez thank you Mr speaker thank you I
was a nurse for 42 years I gave lots of
injections hundreds of injections I
worked intensive care but I learned from
day one if you gave an intramuscular
injection you gave it a certain way for
a very specific reason reason I rise in
opposition to 402 there is a battle for
our hearts and the CDC is winning it but
it shouldn't search the internet for the
CDC pink book it is on the CDC website
it is their official recommendations
regarding all
vaccinations for
decades intramuscular injection were
done with an aspiration and slowly to
make sure that inflammation is contained
in the tissue and does not go into the
bloodstream and Into the Heart in other
words you put the needle back you pulled
back a little to make sure that you
weren't in a blood vessel and if you
were not then you injected it so that
that Med or That vaccine did not go
directly
into into your blood and to your
heart in or around 2021 the CDC reversed
180 chapter 6 now says inject vaccines
rapidly without
aspiration CDC openly states that they
base that on a single study and only
checked for immediate events so
therefore we can put this needle in and
it can go right into your
bloodstream no long-term control no
questions about
myocarditis no concerns about all kids
and young P kids that are suddenly
getting
myocarditis and blood related
diseases zero concerns for died
suddenly we should not release the
general Court's Authority
to irresponsible agencies like the CDC
and the FDA if anything we should double
check everything they recommend please
vote against this
Merchant thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
and fellow colleagues I come before you
ask for is suppor in S sp402 A bill as
amended that removes the barriers to
Patient Choice reduces healthc care cost
while increasing increasing patient
access to
vaccines pharmacists have extensive
training experience making them well
qualified and equipped to handle
vaccinations provide patient education
addressing vaccine hesitancy and
misinformation pharmacists have safely
repeat safely provided thousands of
vaccines patients over many
years pharmacist are available in
community settings as Community
pharmacies which have longer hours and
are more accessible than traditional
Healthcare settings like clinics and
doctor's offices pharmacies are
widespread including Rural and
underserved areas where Access to Health
Care Providers may be limited offering
vaccines and pharmacies reduces
logistical and financial barriers for
patients such as the need to make an
employment or take time off from work
pharmacists can quickly integrate
vaccination Services into routine care
during a medication
pickup by allowing pharmacists to have
greater access providing vaccines that
other Healthcare Providers other
Healthcare Providers can
do it allows them to focus their
attention on more complex medical care
for these reasons I ask that you support
the committee Amendment 1810 along with
the recommendation by the committee a
strong bipartisan vote 14-6 of ought to
pass as amended thank
you and division has been requested
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill on Senate Bill 402
this a division vote chair recognized
represent em Merchant for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know pharmacists
graduate today with a doctorates and if
I know pharmacists have safely
administered thousands of vaccines over
many years and if I know SB 402 allows
patients greater access in choice of
providers who may provide a vaccine
licensed by the FDA and recommended by
the CDC and if I know that SB 402 saves
patients time and money since pharmacist
administrative vaccines are typically
less expensive and often more convenient
than a trip to a doctor and if I know s
SP 402 removes barriers for pharmacists
to provide vaccines allowed to be
administered by other healthc care
providers creating more competition and
patient choice in the market but I now
push the green button to pass the
amendment as recommendation to ought to
pass as amended and I ask for division
vote again motion before us is ought to
pass that amended on Senate Bill 402
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Jones all members president an
opportunity to vote also tend to stay
the
vote 231 voting yay 13 3 5 voting a
majority in the committee on Health and
Human Services LLY affs to which was
referred Senate Bill 419 FN an act
relative the annual data report on the
therapeutic use of cannabis program
consider the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
verica lay on from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being ible
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment and recommendation
Bill ought to pass with Amendment sen of
Lucy Weber for the minority of the
committee majority amendment is
H printed in house record 20 Pages 62 to
are you ready for the question a
division has been requested members take
your seats be a division on the
amendment
hold
the motion before us a minor is the
majority committee Amendment 18928 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos to press the red button voting
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote how attend to state
vote 236 voting a 122 voting a committee
AD the motion before us now was all to
pass as amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I iose
nay the eyes haven't Committee reported
is
adopted majority of committee on Health
and Human Services and elderly Affairs
to which was referred Senate Bill
461 an act requiring healthc care
providers to report certain information
about abortions performed to their
medical facility and requiring those
medical facilities to report the
information to the department Health and
Human
Services having considered the same
report the same the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate repres representative Lucy
Weber the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with the amendment Senator Mark
McLean for the minority of the committee
mlan thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker uh SB 461 requires
that healthc care providers provide
certain health information about
abortion performed at their facilities
to the Department of Health and Human
Services for statistical purposes I'm
here to oppose the committee
recommendation of itl and speak on
behalf of the minority
Amendment while the issue of abortion is
undoubtedly a divisive one one thing
that all sides on the issue agree on is
that there's a great benefit in
understanding the drivers towards
unwanted pregnancy and assessing Trends
in clinical practice and that's why 47
of 50 States including pro-choice States
like New York and California provide
data to the CDC data which is
aggressively analyzed by an entities
such as the Pew Research Center and the
pro-choice good marcker Institute to
better understand the abortion framework
New Hampshire is one of only three
states that does not provide information
and as a result we know very little
about abortion practice here in this
state and the concern why that is is
that New Hampshire has always been uh
there's always been a concern that
abortion data might be traced back to a
patient or provider and used as a weapon
against them and nobody in this chamber
wants that and it's for that reason that
when SB 461 first came over from the
body across the wall it was basically
Dead on Arrival both the clinics and
privacy Advocates alikes were all
concerned about the consequences of the
data potentially being deaggregated to
address those concerns though the
minority Amendment explicitly prohibits
the facility performing the abortion
representative the minority Amendment
isn't before us so okay contain yourself
to the bill
itself
so the the bill itself um there were
privacy concerns with the bill but uh if
we um were
to how can I say this
um if we pass on the ought to pass there
is a minority amendment that would
address the um
the privacy concerns and um give some
explicit rights to basically op out and
I do think that we should have an
opportunity to hear what is being
expressed in that Minority position and
so um I hope that you will uh push the
uh red button and uh oppose the itl
motion to give me an opportunity to
speak to that Minority Amendment thank
Weber thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
Rise to defend the 13-7 vote in
committee for inexpedient to legislate
for this bill so why am I standing here
opposing a bill of which I was a
sponsor well strange things happen in
the place that we may not mention and
this bill which was a very different
bill at Birth is now
completely opposite to its original
intention the bills that came to us from
the Senate has significant issues with
privacy in contravention of our
constitution is recently amended and I
will not sit here and read you the
amendment because you all know it and
supported
it our committee was visited by The
Honorable former member from way
who expressed his deepest
concerns as came to us it says
specifically that there is no
requirement of disclosing personal
identification to the Department of
Health and Human
Services but there was no prohibition at
all about
disclosing personally identifiable
information so it could happen and as we
all know even in the aggregate data can
be deidentified especially when we're
looking at a state that has very small
Centers disclosing a state of residence
which is required in the Bill of a
pregnant person puts that patient of
risk if it's an outof State patient of
prosecution under other states laws in
their home
States requiring as the bill does an
exact gestational age is
problematical as that's usually
determined by an
ultrasound which is not a necessary
procedure and which is an invasive
procedure and yet another impingement on
the privacy of the
individual broad discretion is given to
the
commissioner as to what data is
aggregated and released and how it's
aggregated and released
the bottom line is that the bill has
great risks to
privacy and as we fix the privacy
concerns increasingly the data that is
collected is of no use whatsoever for
Public
Policy
creation because it's simply too
randomized bhhs estimated that it would
cost about a million dollar to enact and
and
effect um uh an effective data
collection system which is supposed to
be done
immediately
finally I note that in our
committee only one person testified in
favor of this
bill and to bring us full circle none of
the persons on the the other side of the
Wall came to talk to us at all this body
voted down a similar Bill last year 205
to
177 I urge you to do it again by
pressing the green button to support itl
thank
you the motion before us is inexpedient
to legislate on Senate Bill
461 a division has been requested
members take your seats as a roll call
seconded no it is not sufficiently
vote
house will be in
order motion before us a majority
committee report of inexpedient legisl
Senate Bill
461 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative McLean for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that 47 of 50 States including uh
pro-choice States like New York and
California gather and Report Anonymous
abortion data in order to surveil and
assess Trends in clinical practice and
Mr Speaker if I know that if we defeat
this motion I worked with that former
representative from we on a uh Amendment
which addresses all of these privacy
concerns including cluding having a
nuclear option to allow any patient to
adopt out of having the statistics
gathered would I then press the red
button to defeat the itl motion so that
um the amendment might be brought
forward and discussed thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representa Weber
for a par inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
contains many privacy concerns if I know
that as you fix privacy concerns the
value of the data that you collect
becomes less and less useful for public
health policy
purposes and finally if I want to
discourage the practice which this house
has thankfully departed from in recent
years but that another place may have
used which takes a bill turns it 18 180
degrees from what it was intended
leaving the names of all the sponsors on
it and encourage them to Simply file the
bills they want in their own names and
not play games would I press the green
button for
itl motion before us majority committee
report of itl inexpedient to legisla
Senate Bill 461 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
repr
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote household attendance stay to
vote 2 on one voting yay 164 voting 0
committee on Health and Human Services
in ELD Affairs to which is referred
Senate Bill 505 an act relative to
Prohibition on the sale of Hump products
containing certain levels of THC
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
Lucy representative Lucy Weber for the
committee representative mlan offers
floor Amendment bills on second reading
open further Amendment represent mlan
offers floor Amendment 2078
H it's in your seat
Pockets chair recognizes representative
mlan speak to his Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I'm here to offer
floor amendment to 20 78h to S
sp505 um the farm bill of 2018
unintentionally created a loophole that
legalized the sale of the psychoactive
THC isomer products like uh Delta 8 and
Delta 9 THC and there isn't much of a
market for these products in states
where marijuana has been legalized but
in States like New Hampshire they found
a booming market and the problem is that
these products are completely
unregulated acidic residue from the
solve and extraction process often
remains behind for consumption and there
are few if any toxicology reports that
have been done with any scientific rigor
so in 2021 to 2022 there are over 2,000
reports to poison control related to
these products and are often marketed to
children as candy bottom line this is
bad stuff this is not the Homegrown or
regulated cannabis that we've been
talking talking about in our discussions
about cannabis legislation Matt Simon of
Granite State cannabis who is we know
has been a longtime advocate for
cannabis legalization he testified as to
the dangers of these products so last
October a ban on these products went
into effect which is going to expire
this coming October now the unamended uh
uh bill is going to make that ban
permanent and while most of the folks on
the HHS committee agreed that we don't
want to see these products being
marketed to kids a significant portion
of the committee also you know looking
at the history of of how permanent
prohibitions work you know they felt
that that might be a bit problematic so
what this floor Amendment does this
floor Amendment takes a Middle Road and
extends the prohibition by three years
until October of 2027 so what can we do
with that three years with the
discussions about the Cannabis legis
legalization still in flux that
additional three years might see the
legalization of cannabis and the
subsequent drying up of the isomer
market in lie of that it might also see
the development of a regulatory
framework that could lead to uh a safer
product for adult use so I think that
the floor Amendment strikes a good
balance a solid compromise that most
people can get behind it's not a
permanent prohibition but it gives us
some room to breathe and I hope you'll
support it thank you Mr Speaker Cher and
Weber thank you Mr Speaker and Mr
Speaker I agree with absolutely
everything my colleague just said he
gave you a very very careful and
thorough discussion of the
problem here's the
thing a year ago we passed a bill
that prohibited the sale of these
products and as you've heard that will
sunset in
October we don't know what's going to
happen with all the other bills I
absolutely agree with my colleagues that
what we ought to do
is when one of the other policies that
we have passed in this body passes it
will take care of the whole problem but
in the meantime it seems
something of a waste of our time and
energy knowing that these products and
agreeing that these products are
problematical for us to continue to put
sunsets that may or may not have to be
um
Extended let's not vote for this
amendment so that the ban can be
permanent until whatever future
legislature
decides to take whatever action they
want to take based on current
circumstances at that time so I ask you
to press the red button to defeat the
floor Amendment so that we can go on to
a motion of V to pass thank
you the motion before us is floor
Amendment 2078 H this is a division
the motion before us is floor Amendment
2078 H this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative McLean for
parliamentary inquiries
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
current ban on THC iser products will
expire in October of this year unless it
is extended but if I know that permanent
prohibitions have often been shown to
problematic we problematic and that the
wider discussion about cannabis
legalization is still ongoing but I now
support floor amendment
20788 to extend the prohibition on these
products for three years until a final
Direction becomes clearer thank you Mr
speaker chair recognize rep Center Weber
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that we're in agreement about
the problem we're just a little off on
the solution would
I vote would um would I
vote yeah I'm
sorry I'm anticipating the end before I
get there I'm sorry and my apologies to
all of you it's been a long day
if I know that we agree on the solution
but not how long the solution should
last for and if I'm in favor of
permanent solutions would I now support
the
15-5
recommendation of the committee by
defeating the floor Amendment so we
could go back to the committee's
recommendation thank you motion before
us is floor Amendment 20788 H this a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if proposer press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay the
vote 172 voting a 190 voting a Amendment
fails those on second reading open to
further Amendment representative proud
offers for Amendment
Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker this floor amend would add the
house version of HB 1633 to Senate Bill
505 House Bill 1633 is the bill to
legalize recreational sales of cannabis
that passed this body last
month when you hear talk about cannabis
is usually referring to products with
enough Delta 9 THC to be intoxicating
however there's other variants of TC
that also have an intoxicating effect
such as Delta a TC which is the subject
of the underlying bill as both this
amendment and the underlying Bill are
about the legal status of cannabis it
makes sense to combine them for a
holistic discussion on the availability
of legal cannabis in New
Hampshire Delta hthc is interesting
another way is federally legal as the
previous speaker mentioned and uh was
being sold in New Hampshire until House
Bill 611 was enacted last
year it was Federal legalized as part of
the bill that permitted Industrial Hemp
my wife recently went to JazzFest in New
Orleans without me and she tells me that
it was commercially for sale
everywhere this is despite Louisiana not
Cannabis however this floor Amendment
and the L Bill are more related than
just
that sp505 repeals the one-year Sunset
clause on the New Hampshire Delta 8 THC
prohibition this clause lause was
included in House Bill 611 last year uh
because of House Bill 611 last year was
the commission to figure out how to
legalize cannabis and it was expected
that the final legalization strategy
would cover both variants of THC myself
and others did not speak out against
House Bill 611 last year because this
was reasonable take a one-year pause
while we make a holistic plan that
addresses the legal sale of both
variants this floor Amendment gets us
back to that plan to address address
both variants together as we all know
the commission failed to produce a plan
and the fate of the actual house bill
1633 which is in the hands of the body
on the other side of the wall is
uncertain but by passing this floor
Amendment this body can stand firm on
its position from a year ago that we
need a comprehensive plan to address the
legalization campus and reject the
underlying Bill's notion of dealing with
these variants of THC peace meal I Ur
you to press the green button and adopt
this amendment thank you Mr
Speaker CH I recognize representative
Weber
thank you Mr Speaker while I certainly
voted for the bill that is the subject
of the amendment under
consideration I simply implore you to
let this bill be a small Bill to address
a small issue but an important issue and
not to get that issue involved in a back
and forth with the other body which has
unfortunately taken a stance which is in
opposition to our much better stance so
I would urge you to press the red button
so that we can send a clean bill back to
the other side and
um defeat the amendment thank
you the motion before us is floor
Amendment 2143
h a division has been requested memb
motion before us is floor Amendment 2143
H this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposer press the red button
voting stations will open for 30
[Music]
all members present and opportunity to
vote 278 voting nay 87 voting nay
Amendment
fails we're back to the original motion
of a to pass representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
vote just a reminder to the members you
can't second your own request so for
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill
5505 this is a roll call vote chair
recognize represent Weber for
parliamentary
inre thank you Mr speaker Mr Speaker if
you know that our committee carefully
worked through the fact that what this
bill does is peel the repeal of a
Prohibition repeal the sunset of a
Prohibition um and we don't want to have
to work our way through that again and
any comprehensive bill can address this
at any time in the future would I now
press the green button to support the 15
to5 vote of the committee thank
you motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 505 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposer press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house attend to stay the
vote 242 voting a 124 voting a the
am
majority of committee on health and
woman Services only to which was
referred Senate Bill 559 FN act relative
to New Hampshire vaccine Association
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation to Bill ought to pass
with amendment of Gary Merchant for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority or Report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate Senator
Mark McLean for the minority of the
committee the committee amendment is
18318 printed in house record 20 Pages
96 through
are you ready for the question on the
committee Amendment all those in favor
say I I oppose nay the eyes hav it
committee amendment is adopted repr
Phillips office floor Amendment bills on
second reading open to further Amendment
represent Phillips office for Amendment
207h just recognize to speak to her
Amendment good afternoon
thank you Mr
Speaker vaccine hesitancy is on the rise
as many don't trust the CDC FDA but
people still believe in
science this amendment enables public
reassurance through
transparency simply put um prior to any
authorization of a vaccine by the
commissioner uh this amendment will ask
that they verify the available
scientific data supports vaccines claims
for safety and efficacy and post a
publicly available report on the
findings of their review prior to the
commissioner's
authorization and lastly it requires
that the vaccine
Association uh video record all their
meetings in their entirety and make
those recordings available to the public
that is not being done right now and I
ask for a roll call thank
thank you Mr
have let me back up uh the problems with
the amendment is written is that prior
to authorization the DHHS has to review
all available summaries verify all
available scientific data for safety and
efficiency post a report the vaccine
Association
must uh record all their meetings and
make them available to the public
there's no provision for extra work for
the DHHS staff and there's ample time
and reason because the language of the
bill is so unclear for people to
challenge whether the department has
done enough or have they reviewed
everything and they must review other
things the bill is very simple and it it
now applies to only one vaccine the RSV
vaccine
children mostly older children and
adults it's just a cold but for infants
RSV results in
hospitalization
and it um can be really terrifying for
both the parents and the child the bill
only authorizes that one
vaccine and we've heard that That
vaccine has been tested as being highly
effective
90% against RSV Associated
hospitalization in infants entering
their first RSV season is it perfect it
is not do you have to give it to your
child you do not but because we are only
talking about one
specific type of
inoculation there is no need for all of
these reviews and studies and other
things I hope you will vote this
amendment down so we can proceed to the
underlying Bill thank
you representative Phillips has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote on the
amendment
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment
2070 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Layon for a
parliamentary
house will be in
order thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the New Hampshire vaccine
Association is already able to pay for
vaccines and if I know that the RSV
vaccine is not actually a vaccine which
is why this bill is needed and if I
further know that because of the lack of
information around this this floor
Amendment provides necessary Clarity so
that people can begin to have greater
trust in the system what I then support
this floor Amendment so we can better
understand what we are putting into our
bodies and have an informed Choice thank
you Mr Speaker chair recognize
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker colleagues
if I know that the kind of review that
is requested here has already been done
and we know that this vaccine is
effective in many many many cases and I
know that is still matter of choice but
I know that we simply need to progress
to the underlying bill to make a vaccine
available more um cheaply for the
taxpayers and the insurance payers of
the N the state would I now press red to
defeat the amendment so we can go on to
the underlying
Bill motion before us is the floor
Amendment
2070 this is a roll call call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
represent
all members present opportunity to vote
vote 166 176 voting aay 185 voting aay
the amendment
fails we're now back to autop pass as
amended chair recognizes representative
wey
thank you Mr Speaker honorable
colleagues respiratory sensal virus or
RSV is a leading cause of severe lower
respiratory tract disease in young
children with approximately 1% to 3% of
the children under 12 months of age in
the United States being hospitalized
each year due to RSV the bill before us
under Roman numeral 9A ask us to make
accessible a brand new RSV biological
product that is approved by the FDA and
recommended by the advisory committee on
immunization practices from the CDC the
bill asked for the administration of the
RSV biological product to Children of
the State of New Hampshire under the age
of 19 years for the purposes of
protecting against RSV so I have a
little objection to that this bill does
not align with the approval of the FDA
or the recommendation of the cdc's
advisory committee what did the FDA
approve and what did the CDC recommend
so the CDC publishes a report report if
I can get there um uh on a weekly basis
and the report from August 25th 2023
States in July 2023 the FDA approved
nurse camab a long acting monoclonal an
antibody for the prevention of RSV
Associated lower respiratory tract
infection among infants and children
aged less than 24 months this was
approved under the fda's FastTrack
program which means there is much more
limited data on this than normal
approvals on August 3rd the CDC Advisory
committee recommended Nur caab for
infants aged less than eight months who
are born during or entering their first
RSV season and for infants and children
aged 8 to 19 months who are at increased
risk for severe RSV de disease and are
entering their second RSV season so what
are my issues with this bill one the
bill is adding legislation where there
is already sufficient access and two the
bill is expanding access where it isn't
needed first all infants already have
access to an RSV immunization or
treatment properly treatment since it's
not a vaccine through Medicaid insurance
and the federal vaccines for children
program which is referenced in the
existing legislation nurva maab was
already on New Hampshire's DHHS Health
alert back in August 2023 for infants up
to 19 months second the product is not
on the cdc's child and adolescent
immunization schedule after 19 months
the risk of RSV is for children under 24
months not children and Adolescence up
to 19 years of age so there are no
clinical studies that would support
safety and efficacy in the Adolescent
population between ages two and 19 years
now there's one more concern this
product was F FASTT tracked through the
FDA process and it lacks uh the full
efficacy data we might see from normal
clinical studies so why is this
nonvaccine product now being
fast-tracked through legislation with
overly broad language I am concerned
that the language in the bill before
specifically 9A implies an immunization
schedule beyond the federal CDC schedule
of up to 19 months and it expands the
common understanding of vaccine
immunization to other types of
treatments with nonvaccine products do
that do not have the full safety and
efficacy studies that other drug
products and biologic products have so I
would vote no on sp599 let the doctors
administer the biological product to the
demographics which with the product is
already approved and let's not add
language to the RSA that isn't necessary
or supported by sufficient efficacy data
thank you Mr Speaker chair recognize
representor
McLean thank you Mr Speaker so the
previous speaker stole a lot of my
thunder so I'm going to basically kind
of try to pair it down a bit basically s
SP 559 defines biological products for
the purpose of assessment determination
by the New Hampshire vaccine Association
so essentially it's allowing the
association to procure and distribute an
entirely new class of immun including as
you heard the monoclonal antibody
products such as the RSD
vaccine one of the things we talked
about and the majority of the community
recognized is that there is
unfortunately a widespread mistrust of
vines that has grown up you know that
came out of the covid crisis and they
therefore felt that this time that the
scope of the bill as originally written
was far too broad and went further than
many folks in New Hampshire would be
ready to accept and so with that in mind
the the amendment that we just passed
the committee amendment is a huge
Improvement because it really larrow
that narrows that scope down to just
look at the very very promising RSV
vaccine um however the minority of the
committee also felt that it would be
prudent to take a pause before we go
forward and the reason for that and was
touched on a little bit is that the
committee heard testimony that the
efficacy data is still rather limited
and is still being gathered but they
also heard that the federal immunity
language around immunizations has not
yet been expanded to include these new
biological immunization projects so we
did the good news is we heard some
subsequent testimony that said the
federal government is in the process of
updating that language to include these
products but that work is not yet
complete it's still in the process so in
spite of that given the potential for
the RSV vaccine to present
hospitalization in infants which we
heard about a quick risk benefit
analysis might lead a reasonable person
maybe to put these concerns aside in
favor of some of the promise that the
vaccine offers however the fact is as
was mentioned the RSV vaccine is already
ready available to anybody who wants it
with or without this bill if you go home
tonight and you turn on your television
set you're probably going to see a
commercial for the RSV vaccine right
next to a commercial for the shingles
vaccine in fact if you want to immunize
your infant it's already covered by
private insurance and if your family
limited means it's covered by Medical or
as mentioned the federal vfc funding so
given the ready availability of the RSB
vaccine to any who want it the minority
of the committee felt that it would be
prudent to wait for the efficacy data
and the updated Federal language before
opening up the door to procurement to
the vaccine Association so I hope that
you'll support the minority of the
committee in defeating the otpa motion
so that we can go forward with an itl
bottom line is we've got the time to do
this right it's already available
product already it's important that we
begin the process of rebuilding public
trust in this very important public
health tool thank you Mr Speaker chair
Merchant thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker and fellow colleagues
I come before you to ask for your
support of SB 559 a simple bill as aend
ended it adds one repeat one vaccine to
the state Universal vaccine program the
original Bill started out with a class
of drugs called biologics the amendment
reduced to one vaccine which was
supported by the
committee house Senate Bill 559 provides
a simple technical fix to RSA
126 q that will enable the New Hampshire
vaccine Association to receive fees from
payers
for an already approved FDA
vaccine that will prevent undue
suffering to infants young children and
their
families each year RSV causes over
50,000
hospitalizations with 100 to 300 deaths
in children under the age of
five it's a lot of
children approximately 75% of the
infants who are hospitalized with RSV
were born healthy and at term with no
underlying medical
conditions
68% of parents say RSV hospitalization
of their child affects their mental
health parents describe the
hospitalization as a financial burden to
their
families SB 559 is supported by
providers and insurance carriers passing
s sp5 59 will allow providers to offer
the same immunizations to all parents
regardless of their insurance or lack of
insurance provides
equality as a government entity the
state may utilize Federal contracts that
significantly reduce the cost of the
vaccine from $500 to $400 a significant
savings that can be helped to reduce
insurance premiums at no cost to the
state at no cost to the state for these
reasons I ask that you support the
committee recommendation that simply
adds one
vaccine
and support it by pushing the green
button at the same time I'd ask for a
division
vote a division has been requested
the motion before us is a to pass as
amended on Senate Bill 559 they say
division vote chair recognize represent
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the committee amendment makes
the underlying Bill much better by
narrowing the scope of the original bill
down to Jesse RSV vaccine but if I know
also that the efficacy data and the
updated Federal immunity language are
still pending and if I know that even
without this bill access to the RSV
vaccine is widespread covered by private
insurance Medicaid and the federal
vaccine for children program would I now
press the red button so that we can take
a brief pause and introduce this very
important immunization in a way that
rebuilds essential trust with the people
of New Hampshire thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognize rep Center Merchants for
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know s SP 559 does not mandate
repeat does not mandate the use of any
vaccine including the RSV vaccine and if
I know that hospitalization of infants
with RSV can create mental health and
financial burdens to many families now
if I know the cost of the vaccine can be
significantly reduced using Federal
contracts now if I know providers and
insurance carriers support the bill and
if I know RSV is an effective FDA
approved vaccine but I now push the
green button to pass s SP 559 as amended
thank you Mr
Speaker motion rece majority committee
report of water as amended on Senate
Bill 559 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 192 voting a 171 voting a committee
majority committee on labor industrial
and Will services to which is referred
Senate Bill 330 FN
relative to allowing the ability to work
from home to count towards unemployment
benefits eligibility consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation the bill
ought to pass with amendment in Brian
Sullivan for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass the amendment is out of order
pursuant to house rule
pass are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I
iOS
nay the eyes hav it committee report is
adopted
on the
majority committee on resources
Recreation development to which was
referred Senate Bill 431 act relative to
wake surfing having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Susan Veil from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation the bill a to pass
Senator robbert har for the minority of
the committee the amendment is
1598 H printed in house record 20 Page
har thank you Mr
Speaker I rise in opposition to to the
committee Amendment for at least five
reasons first the committee Amendment
proposes the same setback that was
previously in this house that was tabled
second the proposed setback restriction
is unsafe for boers it pushes these
water sports into more congested areas
for recreation that will create
dangerous and
unsafe conditions number three
three the amendment further limits
public use and access to public
Waters number
four this bill as amended will not
likely pass the other
body number five this bill offers less
education than the prime
bill so I ask you to please oppose this
amendment by pushing the red button and
Mr Speaker I ask for a division vote
thank
wolf thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
for members of the house I know it's
late and I appreciate you being here to
vote on what is very important to me I
Rise before you today in support of the
committee Amendment 1598 H to Senate
Bill
431 our Lakes are one of our state's
most precious natural resources and it
is incumbent on us to protect them for
ourselves and future Generations we
should not let one group prevent anyone
else from having full enjoyment of our
Lakes I commend the authors of Senate
Bill
431 they have proposed minor regulations
on wake surfing ban wake surfing on
bodies of water smaller than 50 acres
and directed the department of safety to
promote best
practices ultimately the bill increased
the distance from Shore that wake
surfing is allowed to a mere 200 feet
only a 50 feet more than exists
today this amendment that you're going
to vote on will increase the setback to
300 feet and ensure that there is
adequate depth and deep water to prevent
deterioration of the lake we must
prevent the churning of the bottom that
the powerful downdraft thrust of a
wakeboard does in shallow water
disturbing the lake Bottom has been
shown to contribute to cob bacteria
blooms the member the member will
suspend for a
minute it's getting awful awful awful
noisy in here the member has a right to
be heard you have to have a conversation
continue thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for those that are paying attention
to
me there was
69 warnings of cob bacteria last year
alone and in the first three months of
this year since the ice went out there
have been four already churning up the
bottom also disturbs fish
beds having a distance for surfing set
at 300 fet will allow the powerful waves
created by by wake boats to dissipate
before they Rec a dock it will lessen
the erosion that is created by the waves
that these boats generate and these
dissipated waves are less likely to
overturn a paddle booat or a kayak
there'll be less impact on Lon nests and
other protected
species we can cannot do anything about
wind or natural storms but we can listen
the impact of these waves without
hindering the enjoyment of the sport we
can be proactive without Banning an
enjoyment a 300 set foot setback will
support a variety of water activities
without the fear of large waves
non-motorized users of our Lakes will
also find the enlarged area less
intimidating
and more enjoyable paddling kaying wind
surfing and swimming are just some of
the recreational opportunities that will
be enhanced with a 300 foot
setback this setback already exists for
p passenger jet skis at 300 ft and would
be consistent for Marine Patrol to
enforce I want our Lakes to be as clear
and pure as they are today
for my children and grandchildren and
yours if we do nothing time will spoil
what we so love the water will not be
ruined today or tomorrow but each day
that goes by without intervention and
protection will hasten the deaths of our
lakes and many of you do not know this
but I'm a manager of a
5065 excuse me slip Marina that sells
over 20,000 gallons of gas a year I do
not want to ban any type of boating I
love it when one of those jet skis comes
boat I make a living from the lake and
just like the Marine trades we want it
to
exist having a 300 foot setback does not
ban wake surfing or prevent anybody from
using or selling a weight board but but
it's a reasonable compromise that will
help ensure the future health of our
lakes that provide me and many others
with a
living it's time to look forward to
support to protect and enhance our
greatest natural asset our Lakes we can
make a difference and we must do it now
and Mr Speaker I request a division
a division has been requested members
vote
good the motion before us is amendment
order this is a division vote chair
recognize representative en Zulo for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that a 300 foot
setback in the committee amendment was
already tabled already tabled in this
house and is of concern to the Boating
and in and tourism industry and if I
know that voting down the committee
Amendment will bring us back to the
bipartisan bill that actually has a
chance of passing and doing some good
for our waterways waterways then would I
now push the red button and vote against
the poison pill committee amendments so
we can find a winwin on this issue it is
red chair recognizes representative L
Speaker if I know that this amendment is
not a ban but creates a reasonable
buffer
zone and that huge areas of nearly every
New Hampshire Lake would still be open
to wake surfing and certainly not
overcrowded and if I knew that the 300
foot setback represents a meaningful
bipartisan compromise between wake
surfing other forms of recreation and
the health of the
lake and that
unamended this bill shows no compromise
at all among all these interests
and if I knew that if we do nothing to
mitigate the damage of wake surfing we
will end up destroying our beautiful
natural
resources with more cyano bacteria
blooms defeated fish depleted fish
habitat and a dying population of
loons
and if I knew we received overwhelming
emails from New Hampshire residents
imploring us to amend this bill to 300
ft and if I knew that creating ocean
waves in small New Hampshire Lakes is
very damaging to their ecosystems and we
must do something to protect them would
I now press the green button to pass
you the motion before us is amend ment
1598 H this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your poller press the red button
while members president had an
opportunity to vote household tend to
vote 193 voting a 164 voting a committee
members and
adopted the motion before us now is
thank you Mr
Speaker I Rise to speak in opposition to
a to pass as
amended the bill is
amended creates uh as you were told
another 500 ft from the original bill
for the uh
setback uh that 500 ft we've had some
testimony in our hearings that it it
doesn't really substantiate such a
drastic
change the bill is amended is not
supported by over 600 boers and
waterport families that supported the
original bill the bill is amended is not
supported by the water sport
industry the bill is
amended does no more than the original
bill I would ask you to vote down the
bill as amended so that another motion
can be made thank you
wolf thank you Mr Speaker I didn't plan
on coming forward for the Bill thank you
all for voting the way you did
you've heard the arguments they've gone
around for several years and I want to
thank you all for taking the positive
vote to support the committee Amendment
and now let's finish this off with a
unanimous vote to pass the amended Bill
thank
you represent of screen has requested a
it is sufficiently
seconded be a roll call vote members
the motion before saw to pass as amended
on Senate Bill 431 this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill does
not have the support of the state's
marine and tourism
Industries and if I know that this bill
will push voters into more congested
areas causing unsafe conditions and if I
know that by amending this
bill it is likely likely that
nothing nothing will pass this
legislature once it gets back to the
Senate it will
be oh oh excuse me the other body the
other body will bury it and we will will
see this back again next year then would
I push the red button and vote against
uh to pass as amended thank you chair
recognize representative L montine for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that we just passed a meaningful
compromise
Amendment and if I knew
that the vast majority of the of area of
the New Hampshire Lakes will still be
open to wake surfing with the 300 foot
setback that the wake surfing industry
is not going to fall apart over this and
if I
knew that it should not matter how we
think the other side of the wall is
going to vote that we should do the
right thing and do what we have to do to
protect New Hampshire Lakes would I now
press the the green button to support
the aut to pass
motion motion before us is a to pass as
amended uncen aable 431 this a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button you're oppos you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
represent
all members present had an opportunity
to vote how attend to State the
vote 214 voting yay 148 voting nay
the special committee on housing to
which is referred Senate Bill
527 an act relative to student housing
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative
committee the question is on Amendment
17528 prined anoun record 20 on pages 85
chair recognized representative hackin
amendment thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues I support the best
intentions of the house special
committee and housing but I rise today
to respectfully object to the committee
amendment to SB
527 Amendment
1752 attaches similar language to that
of hb1
1281 which was tabled by the house in
March and essentially prohibits the
adoption or enforcement of any code
ordinance or regulation related to the
occupancy of residential rental property
that restricts the number of occupants
to less than two people per bedroom upon
the member will suspend for a minute
let's hear her the end is in sight the
fewer interruptions we have the quicker
continue which restricts the number of
occupants to less than two people per
bedroom based upon the existence of
unrelated or nonfamilial relationships
between those
occupants as a real estate attorney it
seems to me that the beneficiaries of
this amendment will be landlords
landlords who own residential rental
properties in college towns that want to
raise profits by packing students into a
room rental agreement without concern
for buding Neighbors Town culture or
health and safety notice who does not
benefit from this amendment students
won't benefit when they're packed like
sardines into room rentals where there's
an increasing number of housemates and a
decreasing amount of
privacy college towns won't benefit by
this change when they lose their local
control and sadly Working Families won't
benefit as they struggle to find
affordable homes in the same college
towns when more homes are removed from
the market and converted into student
housing which exacerbates the exact
housing crisis we're worried about now
I'm proud to represent Hanover and I
want to make it clear that Hanover's
objection to this amendment is not a
case of nimbyism or discrimination
against college students in fact Hanover
provides an excellent example of how a
college town can take a leadership role
towards creating more student housing
stock and protecting college students in
the rental market so over the last two
years Hanover has addressed concerns
over safety and housing code enforcement
of private off-campus student housing
Handover worked closely with the college
the private sector students and
residential neighborhoods to safely
increase student housing while
preserving landlord Investments and the
nature of the surrounding neighborhood
oods after extensive and expensive legal
review the select board balanced
competing interests before approving a
compromised ballot proposal last year at
town meeting the voters agreed to
changes to our local ordinances that
Define family to include a more Modern
Family structure and off-campus student
living arrangements the voters also
approved a new residential housing high
density Zone to increase privately owned
student housing unit near campus but
Hanover's proactive housing ordinance
and Zoning changes will completely
disappear if this amendment passes into
law and Handover will be forced to
undertake the process for a second time
in as many years to resolve this crisis
Mr Speaker there are three glaring
problems with this amendment first the
amendment has significant drafting
errors its language is vague and only
States what is prohibited rather than
what is affirmatively permitted this
leads to differing interpretations and
increases the risk of legal
liability ultimately local taxpayers
will bear the burden of increased costs
when college towns are forced to use and
then defend a poorly drafted law that
was never fly um fully
vetted second the amendment creates
unnecessary zoning chaos the amendment
invalidates Hanover's recently adopted
and prior zoning ordinances without
offering any solutions for replacement
or how to move forward the bill is
amended will take effect 60 days after
passage which is not enough time to
properly notice and redo our
ordinances third this amendment will
suppress interest among regular citizens
to participate in local government if
all the work that people put into
changing ordinances and Zoning to combat
the housing crisis can be easily
overridden by a state law that did not
involve the same level of collaboration
than the average citizen May grow
apathetic to the municipal engagement
after all what's the point of spending
two years volunteering your time on a
weekly master plan committee if it can
all be undone by the state legislature
Mr Speaker this amendment will punish
the very communities dedicated to
confronting student housing crisis with
Creative
Solutions make no mistake AK what works
for small town Handover and Dartmouth
College may not work for nearby city of
Lebanon and their recently large student
housing project off
campus what works for keen and Keen
state may not work for Rural Plymouth
and Plymouth State and what works for
New London and kby Sawyer may not work
for Durham and UNH this is not a one
siiz all loow hanging fruit problem and
there is no one siiz all solution
to imagine that this amendment will cure
New Hampshire of its college town
housing crisis is an
oversimplification of a complex problem
without any tangible evidence that this
language is the appropriate solution
therefore Mr Speaker I urge you to vote
no on the amendment so that another more
prudent motion may be made thank you Mr
Speaker and I request a division
vote representative Len turat recognize
thank you Mr Speaker I also rise in
opposition to Amendment
1752 hb281 was originally heard in the
municipal and County government
committee which recommended itl by a
vote of
12-6 bipartisan vote in March this body
here voted 307 to 7 1 to table this this
bill or version of the amendment that's
before
you this bill and the amendment was bad
then and it's bad
now the original bill was brought
forward on behalf of two and I say again
two
landlords who have several rental
properties in durm New Hampshire the
Town Administrator of dur Todd selig who
happens to have been in that p position
for a couple decades now presented both
a historical and detailed review of this
issue along with the reasons why this is
a horrible
idea as much as I would love to read the
entire five pages he wrote I'm going to
just pick a few statements let's start
with my favorite sentence from his
testimony the suggested Amendment quote
the suggested amendment to SP 527 and
hb281 is poorly conceived is intended to
support two aggrieved ger landlords and
tries to address a problem that does not
exist I want you to focus on that term
two agreed landlords out of the hundreds
of landlords that are in
durm what about the other thousands of
landlords and Municipal municipalities
that this bill or Amendment will affect
they testified in favor of this right no
in Municipal and County government durm
two AG reeved landlords they testify
the two who just can't play by the rules
like every other Durham
landlord and they want you to override
decades old
ordinances throughout this extended
process we received in Municipal and
County government testimony from many
municipalities and you'll note the
common thread the durm toown planner Mr
selig durm toown administrator the
lebanan city manager the Plymouth city
manager Durhamtown ccel Keane fire chief
Kean community development director and
a personal call from Manchester's
mayor other towns that will be negative
negatively affected by this will be
Handover conquered Portsmouth and Ashawa
now if you've lived in the Sea Coast for
your entire life as I have that's almost
63 years you will recall hearing about
the many problems that existed in
college towns particularly durm and
these problems resulted in the
ordinances that have now worked
perfectly since since the mid
80s well unless you're one of the two
agreed Durham
landlords there are a couple faulty
claims I'd like to talk about very
quickly here by those who are pushing
this extremely bad Bill one is that
college housing is in short supply
that's wrong enrollment at UNH is down
133% in just the last few years and
further decline is forecast to continue
at most brick and mortar
universities during that time in the
last uh few years durm has added 2400
commercial housing units Apartments off
C off campus but within
durm 2400 so many units have been added
into durm that a bus rout to New Market
a town that previously accommodated
large numbers of unh students ceased
operation as there there was too few
students um to use the bus routes
because they had been accommodated into
durm
the other thing you'll you'll hear or
have heard is that derms ordinances
violate the Fair Housing Act again
wrong quote from Mr selig's letter again
durs three unrelated zoning provision is
UN is constitutional is consistent with
the fair federal fair housing a act and
does not discriminate against students
in fact durm was successful against a
petitioner Who challenged exactly this
point in 2010 in that case the presiding
judge referred to a previous New
Hampshire Supreme Court saying as
follows the petitioner claims that three
unrelated rule is unconstitutional on
its face and as applied which pres
prohibits housing discrimination in New
Hampshire the New Hampshire Supreme
Court has addressed the is issue of
whether 3 un related rule was
unconstitutional in durm versus white
and the court noted that while state has
an interest in keeping families together
the same policy concerns do not apply
when unrelated to uh when unrelated
people wish to cohabitate the state has
no particular interest in keeping
together a certain group of unrelated
persons hence this classification is not
constitutional one more quote from Mr
selig the suggested Amendment
s SP 527 and hb281 is poorly conceived
is intended to support the two grieved
landlords and tries to address a problem
that does not
exist it would transition current
Workforce housing and family residences
in our community and potentially and
others to 10,000 pered student housing
and would do tremendous harm to the
fabric of our traditional neighborhoods
and the town as a
whole I think we should actually change
the name of this amendment and call it
the quote let's fix a non-existent
problem so two landlords can pack double
the amount of students into their
properties for double the
income with the large potential density
increases there will be incre increased
cost to taxpayers property taxes paid by
landlords are not going to go up yet
Municipal expenses will police fire and
W rescue Water and Sewer trash
collector as our two Durham landlords
double air in come pay no increase in
property taxes guess who else will pick
taxes okay I was wrong one more Mr selig
quote durm Keane Hanover Lebanon
Manchester conquered nashille Portsmouth
Plymouth New London and other
communities know their local markets
best and they continually wrestle with
how to manage zoning uses for optimal
results for all stakeholders shouldn't
we refer to their knowledge and
experience two words that you've heard
out of my mouth many many times local
control if it isn't broke don't fix it
or in this case don't mess it up this is
nothing but another state impose Central
planning mandate we do not write bills
for the financial benefit benefit of two
individuals who can't get along with
their host Community bills that will
have huge negative impacts on thousand
of the Town residents throughout the
state I'd ask that you join in voting
red against this amendment thank you Mr
Speaker representative Powers recognized
amendment thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of amendment 1752 H to Senate
Bell 52 27 Mr Speaker this amendment is
an important bipartisan measure based on
House Bill 1281 which was strategically
tabled to allow this improved
legislation to be brought
forward this amendment puts in place
clear guard rails needed to protect
Granite Staters from overreaching local
zoning
ordinances specifically it prohibits
outof control municipalities
from enacting zoning ordinances that are
based on familial relationships or
marital status this amendment also
prohibits ordinances that restrict the
number of occupants to less than two per
bedroom unfortunately this legislation
is needed because a number of
municipalities across our state have
zoning ordinances that unnecessarily
limit the number of unrelated people
allowed to live together in fact some
municipalities in particular those home
to our colleges and universities have
what is referred to as the three
unrelated rule this particular local
ordinance makes it illegal for more than
three unrelated people to live together
regardless of the size and number of
bedrooms in the housing unit for example
in some places in New Hampshire it is
illegal for four unrelated people to
live together in a four or even a five
bedroom housing unit while a family of
eight or more can legally live in the
same unit make no mistake the three
unrelated rule unjustly targets students
essentially denying them Equal Housing
considerations creating a scar scarcity
of a available student housing Mr
Speaker this is problematic for a number
of reasons First Property Owners have a
legal right to freely utilize their
private property in a reasonable and
responsible manner that does not pose
any Genuine Health or safety concerns
the three unrelated rule clearly
infringes upon individuals property
rights second to be clear if the basis
for the three unrelated rule is about
health and safety issues then towns like
Durham should not grandfather some
Residential Properties in certain
neighbor neighborhoods from their three
unrelated rule instead their three
unrelated rule should apply equally to
all Residential Properties within the
town such zoning ordinances are unfair
to both property owners and people
seeking housing
and finally unrel related individuals
share housing for a variety of reasons
students might share housing in order to
be able to afford the cost of room and
board and tuition working people might
share housing to reduce expenses so they
can pay off student and personal debts
still others might find themselves in
difficult circumstances such as
individuals widowed divorced or retired
people living on fixed or low incomes or
even those experiencing the loss of
employment as well as the as well as
elderly and disabled persons also
realize that some unrelated people may
even need to share housing in order to
avoid
homelessness zoning ordinances like the
three unrelated rule artificially limit
the housing Supply and drive up cost for
people seeking housing to conclude this
amendment not only complement Senate
Bill 527 study committee for potential
solutions to Affordable student housing
but importantly it provides a sure and
immediate measure towards alleviating
what is a serious issue for students and
others seeking housing in our state and
additionally the uni UNH student Senate
supports
this amendment and they did so via a
resolution for these reasons I urge my
fellow colleagues to support this
important bipartisan measure by voting
yes on the amendment and then the bill
as amended thank you Mr
Speaker a division vote was requested
this will be a division vote members
seats
e
Let's go people the longer this takes
home questions on the adoption of
amendment
1752 H this is a division
vote representative howland's recogn for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this amendment provides a powerful
incentive for investors to buy single
family homes and college communities
driving up prices and making it a
challenge for families to buy those
units and if I know this bill does
nothing to help build one and two
bedroom units at below Market rental
rates that graduate students desperately
need and if I know that d it bonuses
that help developers build those units
are far more effective than occupancy
minimum limits then would I press the
red button to defeat this harmful
Amendment representative Damons
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker good
evening colleagues I think it's
evening if I know Amendment 1752 does
just two reasonable things it prohibits
municipalities from restricting
occupancy of new single family duplex or
multif family dwelling units based on
familial relationships or marital status
and it prohibits respecting the
occupants of a single bedroom to only
one
person if I also know that
municipalities would still be fully able
to enforce State Building and fire codes
and respect public health and safety
would I now press the green button to
support this pragmatic effort to
increase housing that is desperately
you before we call that members are
reminded that when someone is speaking
at the well do not walk in front of them
really the question is on the adoption
of amendment 1752 H this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
will
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 173 in
the affirmative 179 or negative the
all
right so now we are on to ought to pass
527 all right the question is out to
pass on Senate Bill 527 are you ready
for the
question okay division since you're all
here we can yell division in the halls
but there shouldn't be anybody out
the question is motion about about to
pass on Senate Bill 527 it's a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
B members pres had an opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
adopted majority committee on
transportation to which was referred
Senate Bill 358 FN an act relative to
invalidating out of state driver's
licenses issued to undocumented
immigrants having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sen Matthew Coker for the minority
Koker thank you Mr Speaker so I Rise uh
to uh oppose the itl motion on Senate
Bill
358 um the main reason for this is our
country is built on the fundamental
principle of the ru of law no individual
stands above it this principle should be
at the foundation of the debate about
this bill so basically what this bill
does is it invalidates driver's licenses
issued to undocumented immigrants by
other states
um so basically if they cannot prove
their lawful presence that's what it
does and a few a few States actually
Market on the driver's license since
that makes it a little bit easier to see
so sorry I lost my place here all right
so if you cannot prove your lawful
presence within our country the question
has to be asked will you is it right for
us to extend a government privilege to a
person who decides that they do not want
to follow the proper immigration
process is that the right thing to do
it's a tough subject and there's passion
on both sides and I think that's why we
really need to take a look at this from
a rational uh perspective I value
immigration and it's one of the reasons
why our country prospers however there's
no doubt that our current state of
immigration is in chaos if you go 70
miles south of here and go to Boston
Logan Airport you have legal immigrants
and I mean legal immigrants
in the terminal in Boston Logan so what
does this have to do with invalidating
driver's license it has everything to do
with it because having illegal
immigration kind of encouraged by giving
people government IDs throws fuel onto
this fire it causes more problems and if
we value our legal immigration system
and we
value people following the law we
shouldn't be encouraging ille illegal
immigration in any
way so there's a couple misconceptions
about this bill first is is that there's
going to be profiling there's no way to
profile this bill has nothing to do with
profiling basically if the license has
that Mark on it then that's how a police
officer would know and basically they
wouldn't be allowed to drive in the
state um as far as uh the reciprocity
with other states so if you're issued a
driver's license from the state of
Florida and you're a 15-year-old on a
learner's permit we don't accept that in
New Hampshire so you know we do accept
other license other licenses from other
states but that doesn't it's not
absolute we can still have a little bit
of control of that um and really what
this boils down to is again we have a
crisis it's I I travel all over the
country I've watched it move north and
it's a legal immigration crisis doing
anything to encourage or send mixed
signals that illegal immigration is okay
is completely unacceptable and our
neighbors might be able to do it but
here in New Hampshire I think we should
send a strong message that we want
people to go through the legal
immigration process and not take a
shortcut and to think about how unfair
that is to the people who are actually
doing the right thing so I ask you to uh
vote down this itl motion so that we can
make another motion thank you does a
member yield to
questions no member does not yield CH
a thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker s SP
350 358 would invalidate the driver's
licenses of undocumented immigrants
lawfully issued by other states I
believe this bill is fundamentally
flawed and poses significant problems
for our state our economy and our
values first this bill is very this bill
very likely violates the full faith in
confidence Clause Full Faith and Credit
Clause of the United States Constitution
which requires that states recognize the
public acts records and judicial
procceedings of every other state by
invalidating driver's licenses issued by
States like California and Colorado to
undocumented IM immigrants we are
setting a dangerous precedent that could
invite legal challenges and unnecessary
litigation
our state resources could be better
spent elsewhere than defending a law
that undermines the spirit of Interstate
cooperation second this bill creates
confusion and uncertainty not only for
visitors but also for law enforcement it
encourages racial profiling and creates
a potential roadside nightmare imagine a
scenario where an out ofate visitor
legally driving with a license from
their home state is suddenly considered
a criminal not because they've committed
a criminal act but simply because
they're duly issued driver's license is
not recognized here this will place an
undue burden on our police officers who
will need to enforce these arbitrary and
discriminatory discriminatory rules
diverting their attention from more
pressing public safety concerns the
process will undoubtedly lead to errors
further complicating the enforcement and
potentially leading to unjust penalties
for lawful
drivers third we must consider that New
Hampshire is a member of the driver's
license compact the DLC
an agreement among states to promote
driver compliance and ensure Traffic
Safety across state lines the DLC
facilitates the exchange of information
concerning license suspensions and
traffic violations ensuring that drivers
are held accountable no matter where
they drive by invalidating certain out
ofate driers licenses we undermine the
principles of the compact which relies
on reciprocity among the states
furthermore the economic implications of
this bill cannot be ignored our tourism
industry which is a vital part of New
Hampshire's economy relies on visitors
from across the country by passing this
bill we' risk turning off and pushing
away a significant portion of those
tourists who may decide to take their
business elsewhere rather than navigate
a confusing and hosle legal landscape in
conclusion while I understand the
concerns of some of my
colleagues regarding immigration and
state sovereignty this bill is not the
solution it is constitutionally
questionable economically harmful and
morally wrong it places an new burden on
our law enforcement our economy and our
values I urge you to vote green to
support the committee recommendation of
itl let us uphold the values that make
New Hampshire a great place to live and
visit thank you representative Sweeny
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
oh
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of itl and Senate Bill
vote chair recognized representative wal
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the position of the house
is that non-resident aliens will not get
a driver's license granted until their
claims are complete and their permanent
residency is granted if I believe the
non-resident aliens from other states
with the same status should be held to
the same standard if they're in New
Hampshire and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that even under the licensed
compact we are allowed to make changes
to our specific laws then wouldn't I
press the red
button jerich I representative rmo for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that sb3 358 would invalidate
driver's licenses lawfully issued by
other states when driving in New
Hampshire and if I know we want people
driving on our roads to have proven
their ability to do so safely
and if I further know asking local law
enforcement to ascertain on the side of
the road during a routine traffic stop
whether a draw driver is lawfully
present in the United States based on
the policy of the state that issued the
driver's license is far beyond
reasonable or feasible to ask of our
officers and if I know that the New
Hampshire Department of Safety has
estimated at least $200,000 in costs in
the next 3 years to research and
maintain an ongoing and updated database
of in valid license
classes and finally if I know I do not
want other states to decide in turn that
they can void our New Hampshire drivers
licenses when we cross a state line and
subject us to criminal charges would I
now push the green button so this bill
may be put to
rest thank you the motion before us a
majority commited report of inex me to
legislate on Senate Bill 5 358 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
or press the red button voting stations
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 176 voting yay 174 voting nay
for what reason does a member rise
having voted on the prevailing side I
would like to move reconsideration and
no the motion before us is
reconsideration on Senate Bill
358 a roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
the motion before us is reconsideration
of Senate Bill 358 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote
170 house will be in
order 176 to 175 and the speaker did
vote back motion so we're back on the
question roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently it is sufficiently
the house will be in
order a motion before us is committee
report of inexpedient to legislate on
Senate Bill 358 this a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 176 voting a 174 voting a committee
order committee on transportation to
which was referred Senate Bill 469 an
act relative to allowing surveillance of
a park and ride facility in certain
circumstances having considered the same
report the same with a recommendation
the bill ought to pass Senator Mark
paladen for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it the committee
adopted majority committee on
transportation to which was referred
Senate Bill 501 act relative to driver's
license for non-citizens residing in New
Hampshire consider the same report the
same with a recommendation the bill
ought to pass of George Sykes for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative Ted Gorski for the
minority of the committee chair
Gorski thank you Mr Speaker
I stand in opposition of the committee
report of OTP of
sb501 and Mr Speaker I'm a baseball fan
like many in you in this room may
be and every once in a while when you
watch baseball there is an
oddity in which a batter will get up and
see three strikes go past them without
swinging and when that happens you hear
the announcers say there it goes good
morning good afternoon and good
night well I'm going to show you how
this bill strikes out in three
pitches first pitch in testimony we were
told that this bill would only deal with
lawfully present
noncitizens now we never got a
definition of what lawfully present
means according to the feds right now A
lawfully present means stepping on US
territory in your given lawful
presence with little or no
morning second
Pitch the bill states that the director
the DMV May issue a license to a spouse
or a child of an alien
licensed with little or no vetting
so now I ask
you what could go wrong
here good afternoon strike
two third pitch the bill
States quote once licensed the
individual shall be subject to the same
provisions of the law as other
lenses during testimony a question was
asked of the DMV supervisor what that
sentence meant
her response quote I don't
know while we all know what that
sentence means this opens the door for
Integrity good night strike
three with that I ask you to support the
motion of itl by pressing the red button
in putting this bill back on the bench
thank you Mr Speaker and I ask for
division
syes thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
colleagues um contrary to what you might
just have heard the sky is not falling
if we pass this bill okay there are over
currently 55,000 nonresident
licensed to drive in New Hampshire this
bill began its life in the other body as
a housekeeping measure to bring into to
codify some of the practices that
they've been doing for years and years
and years and it's interesting to me
that in spite of all of this the sky is
falling stuff there's been no
documented cases that were brought to
our attention where people who are
licensed under these types of Provisions
have become a
problem on top of that one of the major
concerns that we face as a state we all
know we all recognize that housing is a
serious problem we also we also all
recognize that child care is a problem
the other thing we recognize is because
of those two problems we also have a
problem with employees having enough
people to come and do the jobs that need
to be done why would we turn our backs
on having people who can come here and
drive legally they're here legally in
the United States lawful presence is
defined in the law um and they have they
will achieve their driving privileges by
passing a
driver's written exam and a a practical
if these people are here legally and if
they meet all the requirements for
driving in New Hampshire why wouldn't we
then continue that
practice um I would urge colleagues to
recognize that this is just a
housekeeping Bill really at its most
basic it's just a housekeeping bill that
mirrors and brings into codification
current language and practices that have
successfully brought driver's licenses
to many of the people who live in this
you the motion before is majority
committee report of autop pass on Senate
Bill 501 I heard a request for a roll
call I don't know who made the request
is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
okay
the motion before us is majority
committee report of Auto pass on Senate
Bill 501 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative W for a
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that we do have 55,000
um non-resident aliens driving now and
that's part of the problem if I know
that the position that we passed House
Bill 1118 a few month weeks ago I guess
solves that problem too if I know Mr
Speaker if this bill passes it is going
to guarantee that anybody that comes
into the state of New Hampshire
illegally or a non-resident alien will
be getting a driver's license
uh then press the red
button chair recognize representative Au
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire issues
driver's licenses only to documented
immigrants after they have received
their documents from the federal
government and if I know that sb501 was
requested by the New Hampshire DMV to
codify their current language and
practices and if I know the driver's
licenses issued in this manner expire
the same day as their US government
issued documents expire would I now
press the green button to support the
committee recommendation of OTP thank
you motion before us is majority
committee report of AO passing Senate
Bill 501 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button you're oppos you press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 181 voting a 169 voting a committee
adopted majority committee on
transportation to which was referred
Senate Bill 510 act relative to the sale
of a vehicle to Massachusetts resident
and considered the same report the same
with the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill to pass
with Amendment Mr Matthew Coker for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate sen of
George syman the minority of the
committee the amendment is 1 1925
printed in house record 20 Pages 83
through 85 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
have it the amendment is adopted the
bill be the mo before us now is a to
pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question all those favor say I those
oppose no nay eyes have it and the
adopted now we're on bills remove from
consent calendar
[Music]
committee on Executive Department's
Administration to which was referred
Senate Bill 485 FN an act enumerating
the office of professional liur and
certification processes and procedures
for temporary occupational licensure for
military service members in their
spouses consider the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation Bill ought to pass with
the amendment is
1610 printed in house record 20 Page 72
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it amendment is
adopted the bills on second reading open
to further Amendment repres Spain office
four Amendment 1
19798 and representative poll is respect
is
is thank you Mr Speaker we're down to
two bills so I will make this really
short the amendment is on page 72 in
your calendar this is a bill that we
have passed
before if someone makes an accusation in
a criminal case they sign an affidavit
if it's a false accusation they're held
accountable that is not the current
standard or the nor the current process
within civil things relative to families
it happens in divorces it happens in
other cases if someone's making a false
accusation they should be held
accountable but that is not what our law
says today this bill will fix that I
would ask that you would adopt this and
I would ask for a roll call vote Mr
you the motion before us is Spain for
Amendment 1979 H are you ready for the
question roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently
seconded it is officially seconded this
the motion before us is dis Spain floor
Amendment 1 1979 H this is a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
oops thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
telling the truth matters especially in
situations would in which could impact
the life well-being and future of a
child or their caregiver if I also know
that I have a constituent whose
ex-spouse has levied four false claims
of abuse against him it's her ex-husband
and each time they were found unfounded
and false and it has been debilitating
not only for the father but with the
joint custody he has with his four
children and if I further know that
these cases are all too common and Mr
Speaker if I know this amendment has
passed the house not once but twice and
is deliberately needed to hopefully
deter false allegations not truthful
allegations and lastly Mr Speaker if I
know the passage of this amendment can
help take the burden off of law
enforcement and dcyf so they can protect
they oops so they can focus their
efforts on valid reports to protect our
most precious assets the children of New
Hampshire would I then press the green
button thank
you the motion before us is the Spain
floor Amendment 1979 H this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppose
or press the red button voting stations
repres no he's
gone B members president opportunity to
173 voting aay 169 voting aay the
amendment is
adopted motion before us now was ought
to pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question a division has been
requested members take your seats s a
whole request a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
the motion before is ought to pass as
amended on Senate Bill 4085 this is
going to be a roll call if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press the red button
while members present and an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 175 voting A6 voting a committee
adopted Committee on Public Works and
highways to which was referred Senate
Bill
543 an act establishing the state
environmental adaptation resilience and
Innovation Council consider the same
report the same with the recommendation
the bill ought to pass sen Michael edar
for their
committee for what reason does a member
rise make a motion State your motion I
move to table House Bill a Senate Bill
543 and I request a division
vote the motion before us is the table
Senate Bill 543 a division has been
the motion before us is to table Senate
Bill 543 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative votes for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill expands the size of government by
creating a new entity called the State
Environmental adaption resilience and
Innovation
Council and if I know that this
council's purpose is to make plans for
quote future projections of
environmental changes
unquote even though humans have proved
to be poor predictors of the future of
environmental
changes and finally if I know that this
council's real purpose is to siphon up
federal and Foundation grants and that
the prime sponsor of the bill said quote
I just want them to be able to get grant
money unquote
what I now press the green button to lay
this bill on the table to make sure that
government doesn't get in the way of
real environmental
Innovation thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative cludia for a
parliamentary
inquiry okay thank you Mr chairman
members of the house I rise in
opposition to the tabling motion I know
the hour is late and we probably all
want to go home Pi I'm sorry and I would
uh at pi and I would like to have a
brief debate on this bill which passed
the other body by an unanimous vote and
passed our committee by an overwhelming
bipartisan vote and I think it's such an
you the motion before us is to lay on
the table Senate Bill 543 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose you
press the red button voting stations are
no
all members present had an opportunity
to
vote 170 voting yay 175 voting nay
motion
fails now we're back to
the the original motion of a pass chair
recognize representative
Speaker so this bill has a very vague
purpose
statement as I mentioned in the pi I did
a few minutes ago it states that the
bill focuses on future projects of
projections excuse me of environmental
changes in New
Hampshire by but human beings have
proved to be very poor at predicting the
future especially when it comes to
environmental changes over the last 50
years about 49 significant environmental
predictions have been made and all 49
have failed to come
true if you flip the coin 49 times the
chances of it coming up the same 49
what that tells us is that those proje
predictions of the future are based
on
untruths what this bill seeks to do is
make the most resilient and adaptive
species on the planet
humans more resilient and
adaptive I don't know how the bill is
going to accomplish that
this bill creates a council that has 17
members
17 now prior experience has shown us
that organizations that have this many
members are completely
dysfunctional it's hard to get a group
them I'm not saying that to be funny
house will be in order I'm not saying
that to be funny take the example of the
site evalu valuation committee we just
significantly reformed the site
evaluation committee by reducing its
membership from nine people down to five
people for the very reason that it was
extremely difficult to get that group
together to get any significant work
done so what are the 17 people in on
accomplish there's also a significant
disconnect
between the purpose of this
bill and the UN United Nations
intergovernmental panel on climate
change the UN ipcc has been saying for
well over 10 years now that climate
change does not have a significant
impact on a variety
of situations that happen with weather
and the
increasingly the environmental left has
strayed away from that position of the I
the UN
ipcc and has has taken the position that
climate change is causing more storms
more Tor tornadoes more hurricanes more
drought more whatever and yet the ipcc
says no there is no direct connection
it's very likely that the work that this
Council would do if it ever was able to
get together and do any work could be
done by someone else a single person
maybe the state climatologist could do
this
work the real tip off about what this
bill is
about
is where it says that the council and
its working groups May icit financial
support including funding from state
government agencies nonprofit
Foundations what this organization is
really in existence to do is to apply
for these federal grants and these
Foundation grants to try to build up a a
fund of
money that government can then turn
around and use
chapter now the bill supposedly has a
safeguard in it it says that the joint
fiscal committee must approve and accept
any foundation or federal grants that
the entity receives the council receives
must must also the joint fiscal
committee must also approve any
expenditures but there's no way that the
The Joint fiscal committee is going to
be able to find a rationale to say no if
some Foundation offers this Council 5
million or 10 million or $50 million in
in grant money so it is not a safeguard
all so this bill in short is a premature
Bill there is no mitigation that needs
to be done about in the
environment and there's no reason to
collect a bunch of money into a
fund just because that money is out
there and available so I urge you to
vote no on the motion of ought to pass
press the red button so a itl motion can
be made thank you Mr Speaker chair
cler okay thank you members of uh Mr
speaker members of the House Mr Speaker
I rise in strong support of the
bipartisan recommendation of ought to
pass on Senate Bill
543 this bill would simply create a 17
member State environmental adaptation
resilience and Innovation Council a
council which would meet at least twice
per year and consist of various States
agencies such as Environmental Services
Transportation Homeland Security as well
as Fish and Game among others additional
members would include the municipal New
Hampshire Municipal Association New
Hampshire Association of regional
planning commissions as well as the
business and industry Association and
really not a left-wing
organization um as incl included
indicated in the bill the proposed
council's uh Ro per role would include
fostering proactive planning across
state agencies so as to navigate coming
environmental changes effectively in
cooperation with our municipalities and
the private sector and to those who say
with all due respect that our
environment isn't changing the data is
there the facts are there I believe such
proactive planning could promote more
collaboration and cost saving to protect
our taxpayer investment in our
infrastructure and as a member of the
public works and highways committee I
think that's a very important problem
address public health problems Public
Health threats actually as well as in
preserve a thriving uh recreational and
tourism industry which is a very
important industry for our state now I
want to be clear the bill also
recognizes the exclusive role of the
legislature in enacting policy through
legislation not the propos council it
also recognized that only the
legislature and the governor would
approve the necessary expenditures of
state federal and private funds to carry
out the council's proposed
task and so I just I think that it be
clear what with all due respect to the
speaker I think the data is there the
oceans are rising are are are so many
storms I'm 66 years old I know our
climate is changing because I've lived
long enough to see it uh and it's going
to affect us and affect other parts of
our nation in other ways but we're going
to get our share of uh of environmental
damage whether it's the flooding in in
towns like aworth and cin and I
represent cin and that's a disaster that
is hurting our municipalities but I I
just spoke of the subject finally in
closing you know we may disagree on on
the causes of our environment changing
but I believe we can also agree that we
need to do something we need to
coordinate better our government needs
to coordinate better and I believe state
government should do more uh to ensure
in collaboration with our municipalities
and the private sector uh to help ensure
that New Hampshire remains a special
place in which to live work and play
therefore please vote ought to pass on
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate B 543 and and Mr Speaker I call
call for a division vote a division has
spe
the motion before us is ought to pass
incable 543 this is a division
vote chair recognized representative VES
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this is a money grab that
wants to accumulate money without really
knowing what it wants to do with that
money when I press the red
button to oppose the ought to pass
motion so that a better motion can be
made thank you Mr Speaker chair recogniz
emplo thank you Mr
chairman I believe the bill would Foster
protective planning and risk management
strategies across state agencies to
navigate environmental changes
effectively I believe the bill promotes
collaboration and cost saving to
protect New Hampshire taxpayers
infrastructure I further believe a
mechanism for collaboration with a
nonprofit on funding and Staffing and
establish a fund for the receipt of
federal
grants I also believe that if far
environmentally the lobsters know what's
happening please
vote ought to
pass motion before us ought to pass on
Senate Bill 543 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the vote
172 voting a 168 voting a committee
adopted without objection the clerk is
authorized to
adjust past amendments to bills today
the chair recognized the member from
Auburn represent Osborne for third
reading motion thank you Mr Speaker
resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
the third reading be read a third time
by the resolution that all titles of
bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today it be to
meet Thursday May 30th at 10:
a.m. the question is on a third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I suppose n
adopted the
house members pay
house has an clerk has an announcement
thank you Mr Speaker a couple of quick
announcements one uh obviously the other
body is in today's chairs please come
and see me or make a time to see me uh
before next week if you can I do have a
couple of Senate messages up here as
well uh the chair of Health criminal
justice and finance if you could stop
and see me please also if you could
please clean out your seat pockets and
clean out your mailboxes in the back um
and make sure that if you have snack
wrappers that shouldn't be in the
chamber anyway but if you do have them
please make sure they exit the chamber
with you represent bman mooves at the
house stand and recist for the purpose
of introduction of bills and Rural bills
Amendment Ral bills report receiving
messages informing Committees of
conference are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted hous is in recess